Like you shouldn't be able to to sue somebody for copyright and
then be like, "Uh, now I want you to like go on stream and dance
like a monkey." Actually, I'm gonna make it I'm gonna make it
a part of my copyright lawsuit that you go on stream and dance
like a monkey right now, you stupid [__] I'm not
like a great I'm not a sensitive Jew. I never scream anti-semitism
about anything. >> No, I [laughter]
Dude, no. Ethan, no.
No. [laughter]
We're going to do drama first. We're going to do the Hutch Hutch
reaction to the Casey stuff.
Let's see what we got going on here. Dude, I feel like if I have
to watch Hutch when when they get to the part where she's like,
I'm very upset with Hassan. If he goes,
"OH MY GOD, GUYS. THAT'S OH MY GOD. If I have to watch that reaction
one more time, I might end it all." Okay. I might just You might
see the stream go dead. I might end it all. All right. I don't
know if I can watch it for like a fifth
>> We'll see what happens. >> Hutch, you have my
life in your hands right now. Okay, Hutch, you have your life
in my hands. My life in your hands. Please don't it up. Please,
for the love of God. >> 2024 called addressing Hassan and
his
Might be >> dude, he wasn't just so
there's like a split between people right now between H3 fans.
They don't know. Half of H3 fans believe that Ethan Klein was
doing a tongue-in-cheek reaction where he's trying to make everybody
like where he's trying to like joke and say, "Oh, that's really
that's so poignant, Casey."
Bro, he is the worst actor if that's the case. But okay. But
the other half are like, "No, no, no, no. That's all just totally
legitimate reaction like that. Casey did write it on her own
because here's the thing. There's this there's this other thing
going on in the background where Caseyron admits to saying things
about people negatively even though she like like for no reason
other than to hurt them, right?
And so some people are arguing that Caseyron has
like opened herself up to defamation claims by stating this.
I don't know.
And if she did and it was dictated to her by Ethan, I like if
they go after her again. Okay. If they if somebody goes after
her again after this after the total humiliation ritual, that's
got to be the signal, right, for you that this isn't about what's
right or wrong.
I would hope. I would hope. One would hope, man.
You would hope so. It's got to be a signal that like everything's
Oh, blowing up. We're actually We're not the good guys,
right?
I hope. God, I hope so. God, I hope so,
Dude, it's so crazy.
Anyway, we we keep taking a lookable to go back and um it all
I'm telling you guys, the whole thing kicked off because Assan
wasn't doing anything to rein in his community while his community
was engaged in
what I think is like really disgusting
>> I mean, except saying, "Don't do that, guys. We like
Ethan." Except for that. And I'll admit that's like maybe not
enough, but he did say, "Hey, don't do that. That's crazy." I
I believe he tried to say like, "If you go after Ethan and you
say like crazy in the Discord, then we should ban you, too."
I think the one thing they wouldn't ban people for is for saying,
"I think Ethan's a Zionist or Ethan is a Zionist." And I do believe
that that was like the line. He's like, I'm not going to I'm
not going to tell my community they can't call you a Zionist
when you are expressing ideas that I think are coherent like
and compatible with Zionism.
I think that was the one thing, right? Hassan refused. So I'm
I'm telling you, Jorge the first that Hassan is if if that was
Hassan in the in Ethan's situation, Hassan would expect that
in return, right? He would expect that, but he wasn't willing
to do it for other people. But I'm telling you that the the idea
that he's saying, "Okay, you're expressing some ideas that are
coherent and and compatible with Zionism, so I'm not going to
tell him not to call you a Zionist. You are acting like a Zionist."
I don't like that. I believe that's shortly after he said that
like he said uh basically if you're advocating for like you should
get burned to death because burn people to death, right? It was
like a reciprocal thing, but Han Hassan would have lost it on
that take on anybody else and instead he was just like, "Don't
don't be crazy about Ethan.
Not. He didn't do enough in my opinion if they were friends,
but it's not like he not like he did nothing. And Hassan wasn't
doing anything. I cannot imagine
I'm just trying to think of like
when I would debate when I would get into like heated debates
on the Lib and Learn podcast with my with my co-hosts
and then I started seeing some people um in like not most people.
I think my chat's pretty chill,
but I started seeing some people saying some really aggressive
stuff about Josiah, Econo Boy, and Pisco.
And right away, my instinct was to be like, "Hey, these are my
friends. This is a political disagreement. We don't need to make
this personal."
You know, like I that was my instinct because I'm a better human
being. I I'm just But but I'm just >> I believe Hassan
did exactly that for Ethan. No. Is that not like I'm sorry. I
think he said,
"Dude, what the fuck?" >> Like, that was my instinct.
>> Like, I'm sorry. Not that I don't I think Hassan, you
need to create consequences for people or things don't change,
right? If you don't start banning people who are going like way
too hard.
Yeah, I know, Tequila. I know. I know. If you don't start banning
people who go way too hard, like you have to clean that up. You
have to just like eliminate it immediately. Make those people
make new accounts and and move forward, right? If you want to
do something about it. But he absolutely said, "Hey, stop." He
everything Hutch is saying here. Oh, I said be nice. Yeah, they
he did that.
>> If you know I saw people in my community that were acting
really in a very hostile way towards people that I consider to
be friends
and right away I was like, "Whoa, hang on. We're not doing that.
What are we doing?" >> So the exact thing Hassan did, hold
on, wait, the exact thing Hassan did. Wait, what? Ethan claim
Oh, sorry. Somebody says this is the uh the counter to the the
thing >> Ethan is a mega Zionist. You are wrong. Okay.
Trust me, I don't think you know uh I don't think you know many
uh many Zionists. If you think Ethan is a mega Zionist, not even
close, dude. Time and >> Oh, wow. He's almost like uh chill
chill guys. Hey, chill. Hey, chill. Hey, >> time again.
I've spoken about how Ethan is not your enemy. A person who cries
when a Palestinian child dies is not your enemy.
Okay? He's not. I've said these exact words over and over again.
I told people in this community and people everywhere that will
listen to what I have to say that you have to choose who you
are actually angry at. There are people who are so loud and so
proud
about the ethnic cleansing campaign that Palestinians are are
experiencing currently. Go yell at them. He's been sh on you
on his members only streams. I don't care. I don't care.
Or literally shout on you yesterday and his coworker for saying
from the river to the sea. Sorry dog. I don't care.
I do not care.
This is petty drama. Okay? I don't care.
And neither should
Okay? I will always stand by
>> Okay. I do we even have to watch this whole thing?
Like I don't even know if we do. We have to watch this whole
thing. To me, it's very clear that Hassan did the thing. the
the complaint you should have about Hassan is that he didn't
take enough steps to moderate this like he didn't say oh you
guys have to crack down way hard like like you guys literally
if they're calling him a Zionist like if they're talking about
Ethan basically just ban them that's the degree he would have
had to go to for anybody to be satisfied
and it's really funny that Hutch says this okay Hutch is like
oh me saying just don't go after him we're friends here don't
do that hey what are we doing here that's the bar well Hassan's
clearly gone over that bar what the [__] and when
the community was going like really going ham against Ethan and
and es especially to be honest against Ethan's wife. There was
no
seemingly no instinct
within Hassan to try to like he could have at any point just
said like hey guys I understand this is a really charged topic.
I understand people have really strong
I don't
Ethan Klein supports genocide in Gaza and his wife is being accused
of attacking Palestinian civilians.
I mean, no. No. I I would say Ethan is like somebody who thinks
he's like super pro Palestinian. Probably isn't. Probably has
a lot of like positive sentiments about Israel that aren't really
deserved. But he's I don't know if I'd qualify him as like a
Zionist.
Unless it's on the like when when they're saying Zionist, especially
back here, when they're saying Zionist about him, they're they're
saying something different. Okay. They're saying something very
different. They're saying something along the lines of like,
"Oh, he's totally cool with like yaking everybody in Gaza." No,
I don't think he is. He He at worst is naive in the same way
Hassan is when Hassan suggests a one person, one vote, one state
solution, right? That like, oh, we could just, you know, open
the borders. We We have democracy now. Everything will be fine.
No, it won't. No, that would be really bad. No, that'd be really
bloody.
It's the same kind of like naivity where Ethan's like, "No, Israel's
cool, man. I live there and like they were it was like peaceful
and awesome.
It's just it's a level of naive naivity that's mirrored on both
sides." Hassan hasn't said that. Hassan hasn't said what? Oh,
okay. I might be ex exaggerating. Hassan does do a one state
solution though, right? Obviously, I'm sure I'm I'm probably
actually slightly uh [__] straw manning him because
I'm guessing he thinks there's a transition period where you
go and you need to make sure the violence isn't happening.
Sure, sure. Sure. Yeah, sure. I'm sure. Okay, that's
>> I still think depending on how fast that happens, you
might be a little naive,
>> I I don't watch enough Assad. I've heard his position
described. I don't watch enough Assad to to like go against that.
But now that you say it and I like kind of look at it, you know,
without the focus on glasses,
probably that is too naive for somebody who talks about >> and
want to learn and want to change his perspective. Okay, that's
it.
Ethan has the capacity to arrive at a >> Okay, I don't
know.
I would like to see the thing that would make this way better
is if you had cuz I already he's like done multiple times. Don't
go after Ethan. Ethan is actually a better person. And you're
giving him credit for all of this stuff, right?
It'd be cool to have where they had their actual conflict cuz
where is their actual conflict on leftovers? Is that right at
the end? Is that what that was >> there for a lot of
>> No, no, no, no, no, no.
December 15th.
When did they have their conflict on leftovers?
Do you guys remember? Or was it a members only stream where Ethan
called in? I remember Ethan being on his webcam talking to Hassan
and like begging him to make it stop. I'm here. Sorry. Just I
don't know why I get so emotional lately. Dude, >> you
all right? We don't have to we don't continue if you don't want
to. I don't feel like it. >> I'm not like a great I'm not
a sensitive Jew. I never scream anti-semitism about >> No,
I
dude. No,
Ethan. No,
no, [laughter]
no, dude. This is like um
what this is.
It's like a villain heel turn moment. Okay. Where he like actually
he totally he he says that and it's just like a total heel turn
after >> This is where I felt I did feel bad for him. I
did. Hold on. At this point there were a lot of reasons to feel
bad for him. He didn't he wasn't like attacking people. He was
mostly keeping it under wraps. Okay. He had the one comment that
I thought was mostly excusable about how he had a comment about
and about if you support you should get like burned to death.
But it was really like, hey, if you support burning Israelis
to death, burning like occupiers to death, then you should support
I think it was like Native Americans coming out of their reserves
and like scalping you.
And then I I had to point out that Ethan probably those people
do support that. They probably would actually. >> You can't
I don't even think it's fair to characterize like I'm just telling
you how people see it. >> Ian I know I never said that.
>> Let's agree clearly. That's it. And that's fine. >> I
don't Ethan I don't I've never said any of those things against
you and I and I don't believe that. I'm simply trying to describe
the position of Palestinians in this matter on this front. And
you've done that and I understand, bro. >> I understand.
I understand. I've listened to you. I And I agree. >> I
I'm sorry. I don't I don't want to I don't want to fight. I think
this is like I mean it sucks. And I'm I'm sorry that I I made
you feel a certain way. I'm sorry. >> I wish uh I wish
Adam the guy the Adam Freedelland I wish he'd speak even more
about this. I realize he already speaks about it a lot. I wish
he'd speak even more about it. He should do if you could get
like Adam Freriedeland to go meet up with Sneo and do like street
interviews. [clears throat] I think that would be like actually
just disgustingly good content.
Just go do street interviews in New York all over the place.
I understand people don't like Sneo. Sne's good at it. Yeah.
Yeah. No, it's it would be really good. I think that would be
really good.
>> Oh man, it would be it would be solid >> My community
know you feel a certain way. No, it's [__] up. I
don't want you to I think you're a good person. Just understand
that people don't know uh the empathy that you have and they
simply see, you know, similar talking points they've heard from
other others that don't demonstrate that same empathy that you
do when you're delivering their perspective here. Does that make
sense? >> Yeah. I mean, I'm just trying to have a
>> And I am so dude,
now that I don't have the like blinders on, this is nowhere near
like what I thought it was originally. >> I'm just trying
to be honest and open and like, you know, >> I agree. I
I respect it, which is why I wanted to have this conversation
to begin with. I hope you don't think that I'm like, you know,
harboring resentment or or trying to get my community to hate
you. I'm working in the exact opposite >> Well, I don't
think your mods have a very vested interest in uh aligning their
goals with yours. >> I'll talk to them about it as well.
But as far as like um >> Oh, wait, hold on.
Oh, that's actually
Did he talk if he talked to them about
If he said like, "Hey, I need you guys to crack down." He said
he would talk to them about it, right? That is the exact thing
that I said. If you don't actually change your moderation strategy,
nothing will come of this. So I again, you don't know that he
did anything cuz sometimes he'll say he does stuff and he doesn't
necessarily do it. But how weird is it looking back without the
brainwash? I
Yeah, it's just it's like not anywhere near as bad as I thought
it was. >> As far as like a two-state solution goes, I
think you're or a one state solution goes. Like even having that
conversation alone implies that you're not a Zionist. So I don't
know why. >> But I literally conceded to you that the one
state might make >> I know Ethan. I know. I'm I'm telling
you that I don't I don't feel that way anyway. I don't I'm not
coming from it from that perspective at all. >> All right.
I got I do have to go. I mean I don't know what was I don't know
if this was productive or anything really at all. My sense of
this is that I'm gonna probably deeply regret having this conversation,
but uh
>> yeah. Yeah, that's probably true. That's actually true.
>> Almost certainly. >> That's what it is. >> Ethan,
I love you. I wanted to talk to you beforehand um so we can just
like have a more productive outline for it for a conversation
like this. I'm not >> I wanted to talk about >> what
this is what I wanted to talk >> No, I [clears throat]
know. I just like I like look as as a final statement on this
for everyone that's watching. Ethan is not a bad person. He's
not a Zionist. is um he is delivering the perspective of of a
person that is >> Oh, dude. Oh my god.
This is actually so much better than I thought it was before,
dude. We might have to go back, dude. You should go back and
do like a retrospective on this. Yeah. Oh my god. Coming from
this guy to the guy who's like, "Hey, Caseyron, now denounce
his son or your your dad does your dad's homeless. Your your
disabled dad will be homeless unless you denounce Asan." That's
like, dude, that's so they're like
light years apart. What is happening? >> In Israel, yelling
at Ethan is not going to be productive in the situation or appropriate
in the situation.
>> It's like if if you're trying to reconcile between two
different groups of people, don't you? Even if one group is wrong,
let's say, do you think it's at least even a little important
to try to understand their perspective? >> 100%. No, I
do. I I talk about I talk about the importance of building a
broad I talk about the importance of building a broad movement
all the time. And in order to engage in coalition building, you
have to be consiliatory. You have to be understanding. You have
to be empathetic. Lead by empathy. >> Like if if you want
to call me Israel defending that I'm like,
this is correct. And this is correct. I don't think anybody follows
this example, including Hassan. I don't think anybody actually
follows this example.
I don't think anyone at all follows this example and actually
does it like leads with MPD. Uh including me. Nobody does it
cuz like everybody if you're on one of these sides or the other,
you can't see the other side. Like you can maybe talk to someone
who's in the middle, but somebody who's like a fervent like dug
in person on the other side, you have no empathy for them. You
see them as like >> the most milk toast pro Israel defender
you can possibly find. So like you got to learn you people need
to learn to build a [__] bridge somewhere. >> I'm
not saying that. I hope you understand. I don't >> Yeah,
you're not saying it, but I do think that a large part of your
community thinks that it's clearly reflected by by all the mods
continue to say. And so >> I think it stems from I think
>> I just got a I just got a Air Force ad. Yeah, I just
ran an ad. I forgot to run at the top of the hour. >> All right,
listen. Let me just clarify.
Israel's wrong, >> dude. Dude, that's nuts. Assan Assan's
got a little of that um that Aryan race in him, the scheduling
part. Okay, the trains got to run on time. He missed he missed
the ad while his friend was crying. He's like in the middle he
hits the ad. There's no way the the ads must run on time. >> The
settlements should be removed. And yah, who's a war criminal?
I [__] hate him and his whole cabinet. They're genocidal.
absolute psychopaths despise them. I think the Palestinian people
I think the blockade needs to be lifted. I think there needs
to be I think that Israel is indiscriminately bombing Gaza. That
whatever this indiscriminate bombing of Gaza is [__]
horrific and horrible and absolutely destroys Israel's position.
I I I don't know what more I can do to uh to to to try to empathize
um as as someone who who's an Israeli. I don't know. And so that
those are my positions. If I try to explain a perspective of
of Israeli person, I'm not endorsing it. I'm not defending it.
I'm only saying it because I think it's important for people
to understand the perspectives of of those on the other side
of them so that you can connect with them better. >> That's
that's it. That's my goal. And >> what is your what could
um the pro Palestinian side do better? I think that's a good
question to ask you. Like as far as as far as its own advocacy,
I don't mean this like cynically. >> I'll answer I'll answer
it. Again, I I hate to speak so broadly about the whole movement,
but in general, I've seen and what I'm seeing now is just >> Dude,
honestly, at this point, I actually still don't understand where
they break apart on this. Like, I don't get it at all.
Like, this is still honestly a really like fine conversation.
I actually don't know where they break apart, where things go
Okay, I do Well, I do know that that happened. Okay, I do know
that that
Bro, there's no way, right? Because at some point here, what's
going on?
Uh, when does Dan start emailing?
When does Dan start emailing here? 4
It's It's like quite a bit after this, I believe. I think cuz
Dan, when does the Twitch anti-semitism campaign start? It starts
like the next year, right? Like it's November 2024. Yeah. Yeah,
it's November 2024. October, November 2024.
I don't know when they started emailing. a really viteral uh
toler like there's zero empathy or tolerance or desire to hear
the perspective that I'm doing and so much so there there's not
only a lack of empathy there's a downright um an outright uh
hatred for it. I mean they I feel like a lot of people can't
differentiate between like real Zionist propagandist psychotic
freaks and then someone like me who's a you know secular modern
unreligious uh and concerned person Israeli that's concerned
about what's happening to the Palestinian people. And so I don't
I think that people uh again
>> Dan is at Rome all. Oh, sorry. I'm I'm talking about
like when Dan would have started talking to Ethan about this
stuff cuz I I'm trying to say like people are saying, "Oh, this
is DG narrative control." I'm saying I don't I don't remember
when they started talking specifically. I do know they did. I'm
trying to think of like back here where this where this like
actually starts to happen. I know Destiny was commenting on this
stuff at this point,
right? But I'm just trying to think of like does that make sense
in my head?
Man, Hassan I feel like Hassan could still save it at this point
like really badly. He just needs to keep doing that empathy thing
that he was talking about. He knows [clears throat] the tactic
when he's outside of the conversation. He knows how to have the
conversation. He's described it already. But he is not I don't
believe he continues to employ it here. Once Ethan sort of makes
an accusation that can glom onto Hassan like, "Hey, your audience
is like this. Your audience seems like this." Hassan gets defensive
instead of continuing with the empathy thing. And I think that's
like where this stuff all goes off the rails. Is that required
from Hassan? Probably not. But I think he he could have he could
have saved it still. I can't speak to the whole movement at Broad,
but I can talk about what I'm seeing in your community with your
mods and such is that there's such a quick it's so quick the
condemnation is so quick to interpret the worst faith possible.
There's no charitability. And I understand because tensions are
high. People are rightfully upset about what's
>> Yeah, I'm thinking I somewhere I know exactly when Dan
started talking to Ethan. Somewhere I know this. Okay, I I have
this like written down somewhere. I should see when it was precisely
cuz like I'm saying privately when Dan was privately first emailing
Ethan. I I know roughly when that started happening. I just don't
know.
>> happen I mean that's to put it mildly, right? as you
said, I mean, 10,000 people died, 6,000 of them are kids, maybe
even more 8,000, I don't know, but there has to be if there's
not even tolerance for someone with my perspective, then I genuinely
don't think that there's ever going to be a chance of anyone
reconciling this in a meaningful way. I just I just think it's
counterproductive to look at me like uh the villain and to call
me a Zionist and to interpret what I'm saying as someone who
who's no different than, you know,
Probably the mistake here for everybody, okay, for Israel, for
Palestine, for online content creation, for for everyone was
taking cues on this conversation and how the online conversation
around this should go from two of the most like narcissistic,
egotistical people that exist, who the second like an insult
goes their way, immediately shut down any empathy they have for
anybody else, right? Like that's probably where this all went
wrong in that like they could have the conversation if it was
just them, but then the chats are there and the chats are pushing
them in opposite directions and eventually like Ethan starts
reading like comments on him and he gets offended and then he
comments and Hassan gets offended at his comments and they've
like totally lost a connection to each >> other militant
fundamentalist
settler or fanatic in Israel. >> I agree. I think that
people are too quick to jump to conclusions, especially because
of the prevalence of certain talking points that they hear that
they immediately go, "Oh, he Yeah, but hold on. Simpo, we we've
watched Hassan do exactly." So, we started this off with Hutch
saying that Hassan did nothing to control his audience. He never
once said like, "Oh, Ethan is um Ethan's a good guy." He never
once said, "Oh, we don't we don't go after Ethan." But Hassan
actually did diffuse har more harshly than Hutch seems to, right?
He said, "I'll talk to my mods. I know you're a good guy. I know
you're a good guy. I'll talk to my mods. I'll take care of it.
Right. Like that. That honestly,
yeah, maybe the thing Hassan needs to do here is say like, "Okay,
um, I'll talk to the mods, but we should take this offline cuz
doing this with the chat's not going to be productive or something
along those lines cuz he he did everything right. If the conversation
ends when he goes, I'll talk to them and then he ends the conversation,
there's no schism, I think, right? If the conversation just ends
there, but it keeps going. and he keeps dragging on. >> It
seems like he's defending Israel in the same way that people
look at me and >> "Oh, you're you don't put in a mood only.
Damn, >> you must love it's very obvious that you love
over and over again." >> Um, despite the the endless condemnations
that I deliver, >> I feel that about the the brutality
of it. It's just people are very black and white on the internet
and they want to put you in a a neatly [clears throat] defined
box that says you believe this and I think that you believe this
and you're sneakily and cynically and uh you know talking against
this other position. Um I will not listen to what you have to
say. I simply am going to uh perceive you a certain way and go
along with it. I obviously disagree with that. That's why I try
to uh break through that on a regular basis. I try to instill
charitability in my audience as well when talking to people.
That's >> though in general like I I agree with what you're
saying about yourself. I know that all that about you, but I
do think like on the whole that your community is extremely hostile
towards me or maybe not. I don't know. I don't know how what's
the percent
there's plenty of >> but I feel like they're overly >> there's
plenty of fans of yours in this >> Man, I
I remember at this time I was getting from like people in Desi's
group chat. I was getting um full pages of like comments on Ethan
from Hassan's discord that we were going over. Full pages of
like Hassan's cr Hassan crashing out in his own discord. Dude,
the a logging that was taking place at this point on Hassan was
pretty crazy. Okay, Kiwi Farms. Kiwi Farms would blush. All right.
Kiwi Farms would >> I don't know what's the percentage,
but like it's very I don't know. I feel like very unwelcomed
and it makes me feel like sometimes that this what we're doing
here is kind of pointless, but I I admire everything that you
do and I support everything. >> Oh yeah. What What the
happened? Hold on. Wait.
What happened to Ethan?
Ethan's having a full conversation and he's not losing it. what
the [__]
>> that you do. And um >> it's also I think it's
also because it's a it's a political >> it's a political
community which is cancerous and awful in general >> like
Ethan has the tick still you can see the ticks right but the
sniffing a bunch of the other stuff the coughing none of that's
there >> this morning I talked about walking my
>> his explanation is that his ticks change over time
>> I was 10 minutes into the broadcast and the first thing
I saw in the chat was oh so no more BDS against Starbucks I guess
cuz I said I got a papuccino for my I never said I went to Starbucks.
I never, >> dude. Oh my god. The papuccino comment does
come right after Ethan Sporing out his soul. Okay, that's really
funny. Oh my god, that's funny.
Yeah, a little too narcissistic to have this conversation. I'm
sorry. He really is. He really [__] is. That's [__]
hilarious,
dude. This is like when my when they call you a a genoc a baby
genociding Zionist. That's kind of like when they get mad about
me not following um
uh the
BD BDS. Yeah, the the BDS laws or the the BDS stuff. It's like
me not doing BDS stuff. That's it's the same when they criticize
me, okay, for for going to Starbucks. God damn. >> The
last [__] for the past four weeks, almost 5 weeks
now, I've continuously talked about what is going on in Gaza.
And yet there were still people who are mentally ill and bad
faith who were like, "Oh, I guess you went to Starbucks and purchased
all the Starbucks you possibly could. And that must mean you
hate the BDS movement. That must mean you hate Palestinians in
general." So this [__] happens to me all the [__]
time, too. It's part and parcel of like being unfortunately in
the >> Oh my god.
Oh my god. I just realized I just realized Oh, I had a terrible
relationship when it's like an environment that is ultimately
very emotional that people uh you know, people do the two awful
worst things you could do. We're marrying parasocial attitudes
that are already unhealthy with uh political perspectives that
people get like incredibly polarized on and incredibly impassionate
about. So obviously no matter what happens like if you look at
this kind of stuff and it let let you uh let the kind of stuff
sway your opinion it's going to destroy you mentally. >> Bro,
we got we got like 2 minutes into the Hutch reaction and he was
like Hassan didn't do this thing that I did and then it's like
yeah he did. He totally did. He did that precisely actually.
And when the
community was going like really going ham against Ethan and and
es especially to be honest against Ethan's wife, there was no
seemingly no instinct
within Hassan to try to like he could have at any point just
said like, "Hey guys, I understand this is a really charged topic.
I understand people have really strong
I don't agree with Ethan,
but let's all just try to have respect for each other. That's
all that's that's
all he could that's all he had to say. That is all he had to
say. >> He said that multiple times. >> And that
boy, we >> we already, >> you know, that small gesture
I think would have gone that that would have had a tremendous
impact. That would have brought brought the temperature down.
Dude, there's no way. Why does this guy say like this? Even I
knew, bro, I'm so much I am the ultimate. I have hung the the
the shoes up or the the gloves up. Okay, I'm no longer in that
ring. But I was the best Hassan Alog by far. I was the best Hassan.
I'm so much better than Hutch at this, dude. If I just kept if
I just been like, "Yeah, Destiny sucks, but I'm still going to
hate Hassan." And I just grinded on the Hassan hatred, bro. I
would have popped off. I know it. Cuz I don't up like this. I
don't say like this that gets me nuked later. I'm sorry. I don't
I I'm sorry. I don't. You wouldn't have You could just be honest
about Hassan. That's what I do. That's what I do.
Bro, I I always go after Hassan. I That What do you think it
is when I laugh at how he's such a narcissist? Do you think that's
like Do you think the Hassan community appreciates that when
I call him a narcissist who's like borderline inhuman sometimes
and how he handles other people's emotions? Yeah. >> Completely
eliminated the total psychopaths that were,
you know, spreading animations of Ela murdering Palestinian children.
Like, you can't 100%.
Is there Wait, is there anybody who posted that animation in
his Discord or anywhere like any of his communities that wasn't
banned? Like, is there is there anybody I understand that animation's
offensive, but is there some reason or is there some proof that
they let that animation get posted then just didn't care? I I
feel like I feel like they were moderating it for a while, right?
Because I remember I looked at I remember I covered logs where
somebody posted it. I could have sworn they got
>> but maybe like weed out all those people. But Hassan
could like just by setting that example
could have taken a that would have been a meaningful action to
bring that temperature down and he just refused to do it and
he pretended like
it.
One of your cancellations on the desk was you wanting to gay
ops on. Oh, that's true. But like that was just me.
I'm, trust me, I'm like kind of a lazy person. So instead of
actually doing any kind of like gayop or sciop, what I actually
do is I just say, "Oh, it'd be really funny to do this and then
I hope that that clip will eventually make it to that person
and they'll think it's happening." I'm like too lazy to actually
go out of my way to do it. So I think I was like, "Oh, we should
totally like we should totally like fake that we tried to get
Hassan kicked out of the DNC. That would be really funny if you
believe that." That's the gay by the way that we should make
Hassan think that we did something that we didn't do.
That's like the crazy oh evil thing apparently.
Not that we did do it. And obviously I put it on the record that
I was saying it would be funny if we did do it and we took no
steps to actually do it. But okay outside of his power. There's
a 10-minute compilation of him just doing that. You're just lying
then. Hang on. Then why did why during [laughter] >> It
is wait. Yeah does this too now that I think about it. I don't
think I hung out with Queen a ton back then. He probably came
on sometimes, but I don't think we hung out a ton. Dude, that
was uh
Yeah, I know he does that as well. To be fair, his community
more actively pursues that those gay ops, those things, those
hypotheticals. My community, I make it clear, don't >> conversation
that Ethan and Hassan were having with each other
and Ethan is like asking Hassan to take more steps to moderate
his community.
Why did Hassan say, "Well, I can't I can't There's too many people.
I can't I can't stop it." Why did he do that?
what was the precise quote now? We just went through it and I
don't even remember the precise quote. Um
I don't One second. One second. Not >> by way. I'm not
even defending the I'm not even like I'm just tell I'm just trying
to tell you guys how it feels. And I'm [__] shocked
that you don't care that people in your chat are saying, "Who
the [__] is this child?" Cold, arrogant, >> I
love you, but there's but there's only so much I can do. >> How
can you be surprised when your Discord is literally full of [__]
>> Ethan? I love you, but there's only so much I can do
if you're making that argument. You know that, right? Like, at
a certain point, you're an adult and the words that you're saying
are going to be perceived by people in a certain way. I can't
constantly tell my community to shut the up, like, which I have
and I think they should, but in at the end of the day, it's because
I know you personally, and I think your heart is in the right
place, but they don't know. So, it's hard. It's hard for people
to to view what you're saying beyond your perspective. You disagree.
That's it. I mean, what the do you want from me? >> Okay.
But but do you get do you get where I'm coming from? Like
>> like Okay, he could have. Again, the the empathy could
have been here. But Hassan starts getting criticized. It's rough.
Okay. It's rough. That that clip is unfortunately for Hutch surrounded
by by Hassan repeatedly going, "Don't go after Ethan. He's a
good guy. You guys are wrong. You guys are wrong. You guys are
wrong. Even though you can't see it. You're wrong. You're wrong.
You're wrong. wrong, right? If it wasn't bookended by him repeatedly
saying, "You're wrong. Ethan's a good guy. Don't go after him."
Then I would feel less confident in saying, "Oh, he took those
steps." This is like the one part where he's like, "Okay, like
at some point people are going to think that you're not like
you're not c you're not couching the message. You're not like
trying to make it land soft, right? That's going to happen."
And I I didn't give him that charity previously. I can I can
see where he's coming from now. Okay. A little bit better. That's
that's the clip. So, it's uh I can't help you when you say things
that could be perceived this way. Like sometimes people are going
to say that. I can't make that not happen.
That's not even like we won't moderate it. It's not He already
said he talked to his mods, right? He's he's just saying that
you're going to get comments like that. And I think if you put
together all of his rationale, right? Oh, I do things that step
outside the lines barely. I get tons of hate from my community.
Bunch of people freak out on me, right? Oh, one second.
Uh >> anonymous, thank you for the gifted sub. Let's go.
Thank you. Thank you. So, I get hate from my community over like
the papuccino or whatever. He's trying to say that there's a
really outsized reaction when you do things that could be interpreted
negatively. There's a really outsiz from the super soy community
or outsized reaction, sorry, from the super soy community that
I've built. You have to deal with that. You have to that's it's
just how it is. Okay.
And
he he's saying I can't even fix it for myself. So, how could
I fix it for you? I think is the general direction he's trying
to go in there, but it certainly could be read a different way.
Like, oh well, you're an you. Do you have to deal with it though
with that though? Just ban those people. Well, I think he said
he was going to talk to his mods, right? He said, Ethan is a
good guy. He's not a Zionist. You guys are going crazy and I'll
talk to my mods. Like he that's the critical thing for me is
he said, "I will talk to my mods." And then Ethan just kept kept
on saying, "These people are crazy. These people are crazy. These
people are crazy." >> Why didn't he say, "You know what?
Yeah, I can I can do that. >> No, it doesn't. Moderation
doesn't stifle growth at all. I'm sorry. Moderation doesn't stifle
growth.
Um, I do this sometimes. Probably a big thing I need to do with
my channel is not worry about like uh don't sweat the small stuff
kind of thing. Like I I should probably not worry about moderating
people as much. I should not worry about it. You should do things
that actually scale. If you're if you're running into like scaling
issues, it's not because you're like not banning It's not because
you're banning people or not banning people. Nothing to do with
that. It's the content. Okay,
>> I can start telling them. >> Yes, it does. Oh,
yes it does. Look at Chud with EHD.
Um, that's because Chud isn't doing Chud built a channel around
doing content centered around like the specific community, right?
Like he built a channel originally from that and it's massive.
I like it's me when I don't cover I feel the same thing. Okay,
Chud did move away from the Destiny stuff, but he built the channel
originally with people who are interested in that, right? And
so while those people don't need him to cover the Destiny stuff,
cover whatever Destiny stuff all the time and they can be fine
with that, when there's massive drama happening in those adjacent
communities and Chud avoids it still, I think that can mean they'll
go somewhere else to watch it,
But that's fine. He's he's shedding the last of that community.
This will this will be the last of that community that he sheds
and then he can he can grow out in a different direction, right?
So you think the soy freaks aren't integral to Hassan's community?
Well, I'm sure they they are integral, but I'm saying that the
people who are basically calling Ethan something crazy. They
call Ethan a Zionist, I don't think you have to ban them. If
they call Ethan like a crazy bloodthirsty Zionist baby murderer,
then you can probably ban them, right? Like there's a there's
just a degree you just set the bar and say, "I want people banned
who do anything worse than this." Not difficult. No, no, no.
It's I Dude, Chud's really entertaining. I love watching his
content today. I watched for a little bit, but I'm saying that
there's big things happening in adjacent communities. It's like
when I would not cover like food shops a logging my community.
Well, then my community is going to go watch her a log my community
to like laugh at her, right?
But I built a community. I built like a community around fighting
with people. If I'm not fighting with people, they aren't going
to go watch people who will fight with people. You have to like
slowly transition to something else, right? Which I don't mind
fighting with people. I just didn't want to fight with a like
an actual currently arguing with Dan over who's going to actually
do it. Dan can do it. Listen, she's not going after me, okay?
She's not going after my She's not saying my family deserves
to be doxed. That's She's saying that about Dan. Not saying that
about me.
Okay. At least you're honest. Well, sometimes. Sometimes. Sometimes.
We'll see. We'll see what happens with that. Maybe we'll go through
that at some point if the content runs dry. >> Anyway,
we can do this. >> I can't remember what my Oh, um, you
were saying has like Chud was shrinking from not covering the
EHD stuff. >> Um, no. I think one is there's like a drama
drought right now. And this is the big thing. That's the other
thing. There's a there's a drought on other stuff. And this is
like a reliable well of content and it's going to be for the
foreseeable future, right?
She said Connor was his kids. Wait, did she though? Did she say
that? Cuz I know I know Riyle said that too. I know Riyle said
that to um Connor and Connor's a
I saw that clip. I don't think we covered it on stream. Did you
guys see that? I don't want to out rile, but this a Cheeto like
this a Cheeto guy came to my channel and he said he said he said
that uh that I food shop said I my kids.
By the way, I think it's super funny
food shops watches Perry. Okay, cuz if you don't know that's
like the Perry line and food shops is just repeating Perry, which
listen Perry's very funny, but you have to understand Perry's
satire. If you want to be like taken seriously in some way, you
want to have serious opinions, don't repeat what Perry says.
Okay,
that is that is the Perry commentary on um on Connor that like
Connor's
kids or some [__] It it was it's crazy stuff. All
right.
Uh so I I just think it's nuts that
that food shops watches Perry seems weird. >> No, do do
like 24-hour bans for that kind of thing. Like he could have
implemented policies. He could have implemented moderation policies
within his community right then and there in that moment. And
I don't I have no idea what prevented him from doing that.
Was it because he he knew his audience had been been uh extremely
radicalized and he was afraid of alienating his audience? Maybe
that was it. I don't I don't know.
Um, Hassan defending Ethan post leftovers is a freaking joke.
He essentially told his audience to shut up about Ethan, but
didn't disagree with their comments. Real Kathy Doyle, you didn't
have an issue with Destiny's whole community were ruthlessly
going after you without any moderation.
Huh. Good one, Kathy. Here's a clip of food shops talking about
Counter Kids. Okay, let's check this out real quick. Real quick.
thinking that Counterpoint is the most terly online boomer that
has ever existed is ever going to be doing anything busy during
his his like daytime or night time. He probably doesn't even
take care of his kids, okay? Like, bro, he dude, this Okay, this
is probably not even like cuz he's busy thinking about his kids
too much, okay? Conor, like Jesus Christ. Oh my god. Just do
something with your life for once. Like, if you're going to be
online, then might as well just like do it out. Don't pretend
that you actually live in the IRL world, okay? when you're like
one of the most terly online people out there. >> Okay.
I I don't know. I I That seems like wild that she watched Yeah,
she watched Perry and just repeated what he said with no context.
I don't know if you guys know this. Perry sometimes just makes
things up because he thinks it's funny. I would I would not just
copy the things he says. Sometimes he just makes them up totally
entirely whole cloth.
What is he drinking? I have no idea.
Connor's 100% parrot. Yeah, I know. I know. I listen. Trust me,
I listen to of the one Perry stream I've listened to like in
full. Well, no, that's not true. I watch Perry sometimes. He
just doesn't stream very much. He streams like while I sleep.
So, um, but one of the streams I've watched in full that was
really funny was his whole counterpoint segment. Perry's like
Perry's like this thing that goes from like serious commentary
and he crosses into like total hyperbolic satire and it's very
funny if you're a content creator. It's like all the things I
would want to do if I just didn't care about people taking me
seriously at all. You know, uh, I was in Perry's chat 3 days
ago and Fujobs got gifted a sub. I've never seen her in chat,
her chat. Just remembered. Oh, interesting.
>> Okay. Anyway, that's She's copying the Perry bit. It's
crazy. >> What? What are we talking about? Okay. Anyways,
let's review the uh
apology and we'll look at the uh Denim's thing. >> Yeah,
Hutch's review
and then I think I've got Denim's reaction as well. So, we'll
do the Denim's reaction.
end by stating I take responsibility for infringing the content
nuke. >> Oh, wait, wait, wait. Sorry. I've got Hutch's
reaction to the denim suite. This is my bad. >> I want
to begin by stating I take responsibility for infringing the
content nuke. The lawsuit was not frivolous. When I said the
lawsuit was frivolous and based on misogyny, it was to garner
sympathy, protect my own reputation, and retaliate against the
clients.
This lawsuit has given me a greater understanding of copyright
protection, people's copyrights, and the importance of protecting
copyrights in the online content creation community. >> This
is um
there's just this insane
there's this insane talking out of both sides of your mouth situation
that occurs with all of the H the pro H3 people. Okay? Somehow
they'll they'll say this is all about copyright. They'll keep
saying this is all about copyright. This is all about copyright.
And then you'll ask, okay, why is there 30 seconds of her talking
about copyright and then why is there like 2 minutes and 30 seconds
of her just litigating drama?
Why was that why was that a part of a settlement, right? And
they'll be like, well, no, but like he wanted he wanted to humiliate
her cuz she was like saying crazy things about him. She was she
was like totally defaming him. Okay, then don't you file for
a defamation lawsuit for that? What the [__] are
you doing?
like you you've just everybody admits that it's a totally disingenuous
copyright suit, but also sorry disingenuously like maliciously
pursued. Not disingenuous in terms of it doesn't work like disingenuously
pursued, right? You pursued it for other goals. You didn't care
about enforcing your copyright. You don't care about enforcing
copyright. That's not your problem. That's not your goal. What
you want, what you do care about, what you want to do is go after
people who said mean things to you. And that's evident in her
reply in your lawsuit, right? your lawsuit that compares Assan
to or the the grand muty of Palestine that met with right it's
obvious that you're just litigating online drama that's what
you really care about but you know you can't sue for defamation
you know that you don't you would fail horribly you have been
sued and and settled successfully and lost on defamation
but they they try to have it both ways oh no it's a totally legitimate
copyright suit and and he pursued it for that reason but also
Casey Trump sucks Trump sucks that she lied about him She lied
about him. She made things up about him. Also, don't you know
about the skulls? Don't you know, guys? The Skullost industry
is the is has been disastrous for the online drama content creation
space. Okay, we have to we have to dethize the the Skullocost.
We have to work to make sure it's understood. Okay, we have to
we can acknowledge that the Skullost was bad. We cannot try to
reframe or rewrite history. We can acknowledge it's bad and say
that it doesn't affect things in the current day. Okay, we all
need to agree that the skull cost is while it was real and it
was bad, it was terrible. Uh it does not matter now. Okay,
that's that's just how it is. >> It is important for the
entire content creation community to respect the intellectual
property rights of other creators and I will adhere to the lessons
I've learned throughout this process going forward.
I also want to make clear that I did not receive any support
financial or otherwise. >> Sorry. Yes, he did lose. He
He lost in terms of a settlement. Yes. >> From Hassan [__]
>> Oh, man. Wow. Wow. Wow. Wow. Wow. >> Hassan never
even reached out to me privately to offer words of support. Speaking
honestly, I found his indifference to my suffering hurtful, especially
after he hinted he might help me behind the scenes. It felt like
he wanted to receive credit from the public for helping me without
providing any.
That is exactly what happened. By the
>> I agree. I agree. I just know in my mind I just know
that Hutch is just doing a Willy Mack. He just had his Willy
Mack moment. Oh, this is all true, by the way. This is all true,
by the way.
>> Exactly what happened.
and he brought it on himself because he
they Okay, I for the record I do believe that that Hassan didn't
reach out to her and probably didn't provide her money. Might
have maybe through an anonymous thing, but probably didn't. Okay,
I I agree with those things, but I think it's crazy to do this
thing I see a bunch of content creators, pro Ethan content creators
doing where they watch this video and they go, "Thank God Casey
is saying this. Thank god the truth. Thank god Casey has had
a a critical realization of her conscience and she has she's
come out and she's speaking sorry she's spoken on this in a way
that is you know it's giving us moral clarity on the Hassan issue.
It's like, dude,
just Oh my god. This is not She's not had a an attack of conscience.
She has not had a come to Jesus moment. She There's nothing like
that has happened. She is like reading something that is written
for her. Are people acting like this is actually genuine? They
are both They're doing both Koser. They're saying they're saying,
"Oh my god, thank God she's saying all these true things. Thank
god she's saying all these very true things that she believes."
But also going, "No, no, no. She's like being forced to say it.
And that's what makes it funny because there's a apparently there's
another undercurrent here which is people think that she's admitted
to defamation here in in some element of this. They believe she's
admitted to defamation and so they want her to be held responsible
for the defamation while also clearly seeing that it's a hostage
video. Yes.
That that she's got a machete to the back of her neck right now.
Okay. It's I People can't Dude, people can't stay consistent
on it and it's super embarrassing for them. So all of the all
of the reactions to this are never going to be how like, oh,
it's great that we finally gotten justice. It's great that like,
oh, we can, you know, it's great that Ethan is doing this. I
love that Ethan did this. It's it's so awesome. No, almost nobody
is saying that precisely, right?
What they're saying is, "Oh, Casey Tron, I'm so happy she's humiliated.
This stupid [__] This stupid." That's all they can
do, right? And they'll never comment on like, "Oh, what are the
broader implications of this? that this rich loser can go after
anybody and he doesn't go after them, okay? He can create videos
and if you react to this rich log loser freak and he decides
he wants to sue you because you were mean to him, he'll do that.
He'll use copyright to do that. He'll use the Library of Congress.
He'll go to the Library of Congress, he'll register his and then
he'll try to sue you and he will try to dominate you financially
so that he can get you to apologize for your drama coverage.
And it's it's disgusting. It's obviously disgusting. Can you
imagine? >> He very clearly implied that he was going to
help these people. He didn't have to say that. He didn't have
to say that. You know,
if you're if you're not going to follow through, then don't like
that's exactly what happened. Like what she said was 100% accurate.
In a technical sense, he probably could have donated like 500
bucks. Realistically, what I think what I think is a possibility,
maybe higher than just a tiny possibility, is that he donated
like a 100red or 500 bucks when realistically he's got way bigger
way way bigger pockets than that and realist he can't even go
public with his donation cuz his donation would have been so
small that it would be embarrassing to go public with it. I think
that's entirely possible. He wanted the appearance
of being like the good supportive guy protecting these creators
against evil, you know, Israeli Ethan
and then he just didn't do anything about it. >> As to
the GoFundMe money, to the extent there are any remaining funds
after >> Oh, also quick question. Was it obvious the whole
time that Hassan was going to get the GoFundMe money? If yes,
if you argue, oh, we knew this. We said this, we said this, guys.
Hassan was Ethan was always going to get the GoFundMe money.
We said this, we knew this. We knew this, guys. If that's true,
then why would you expect Hassan to donate? How involved is Destiny's
friend Dan with this? Um, like as much as one possibly can be
as an outsider,
like literally maximally. Like he presented the strategy to Ethan
directly on how to do this, how to register the copyright so
that you could get statutory damages and actually pressure these
people to off. Yep. Like entire like all all of the >> Think
about it. >> As to the GoFundMe money, to the extent there
are any remaining funds after I pay my attorney's fees, I have
agreed to pay the remaining funds to the clients. The funds will
not go any to any >> now. Now, now hold on. Like I man
Koser, you got to get out of here, okay? Cuz I I can't. It's
really bad optics to have you here while I cover this, okay?
You got to you got to go cuz like I'm sorry. Two rich people
coming together to like make this person submit to their whims
through litigation.
>> I'm just saying the optics of that >> in terms
of people who are concerned about anti-semitism, it doesn't seem
like they're super concerned. Seems like they're trying to create
as much of this thing in the world as they possibly can. And
I don't know why. Very curious. What are their goals? What are
they attempting to do?
What are they attempting to do? It's very curious to >> Anyone
else, including Denim? >> Oh. Oh, Matt. Matt, thank you
very much. I actually just reset the timer and didn't even say
anything. Matt NLT, thank you so much. Huge 10 gifties. Thank
you. Thank you. Thank you. Let's [__] go. Not seeing
a connection. Must be a coincidence.
The funny thing is is Yeah. No,
exactly. That's how people argue. It's unfortunately when you
start to see the things when when total skits get vindicated
repeatedly over and over and over again, you start to think like,
wait, wait, those skits have a point? I think that's what a lot
of us are experiencing at this point. Okay. And yet, in the world
where skits seem to be stacking W's every single day, they seem
to be vindicated again and again and again and again, Candace
Owens can't catch a single W. How? How is she managing this?
Yeah. Okay. She can't catch a single W fact factually,
150,000 live viewers. Yep. Make it make sense. Somebody make
it make sense. >> Or Frogan to defend their lawsuits.
For the record, I have agreed to cooperate with the clients in
their litigation against the H3 snark mods for promoting my live
stream to the extent that I am able. I will offer my support,
including testifying under oath to everything I have just stated,
to help their cause. I also want to take the opportunity to acknowledge
other misconduct and bad behavior I have exhibited online.
For example, weaponizing the death the death of Asmin Gold's
mother was inexcusable.
I should know better because I have three disabled people that
rely on me. >> There was somebody else too. Uh,
like do we need legislation to protect influencers from being
compelled to make statements outside of the actual thing like
the actual like criminal conduct or the illegal conduct?
Like you shouldn't be able to to sue somebody for copyright and
then be like, "Uh, now I want you to like go on stream and dance
like a monkey." Actually, I'm going to make it I'm going to make
it a part of my copyright lawsuit that you go on stream and dance
like a monkey right now, you stupid [__] Go on stream
and dance around, twirl around like a monkey. actually go do
your dance. Wait, where's the clip? I don't have the Casey clip,
do I? Somebody get me the the Casey clip right now of her dancing.
Okay, Ethan Klein's like, "You need to recreate this clip for
me." Except you get all of the uh all of the
the hummus panelists, okay? They have to be the gay guys making
out in the corner. Recreate that and then I won't take your dad's
house. I won't take your house from your disabled parents, you
stupid [__]
Yeah, it's a settlement. She's effectively being paid off to
do the statement. Yes, sweatpants freedom. I'm saying that, okay,
let's say
let's say hypothetically Ethan was suing somebody who actually
did like a full reaction to that video and he was suing them
for that video and and that they they did a full reaction and
it's basically on the par or better than anybody else's reaction
in the React game. Okay,
let's say hypothetically Ethan was doing that and let's say that
person didn't make very much money and they had to actually go
hire lawyers and they were being financially devastated by this.
They would have to do the same thing that Caseyron is doing regardless
of how likely they are to win.
It wouldn't matter how likely they are to win. They would be
right.
So that's what we're really worried about is, you know, okay,
Casey Tron, hard to defend Casey Tron's lack of reaction, right?
>> The Casey Tron dance. God damn it. God damn it, Smatic.
God damn it. I just trusted you. No more trust. 0% trust. They
could declare bankruptcy and keep their dignity. Um, do you get
to keep your home when you declare bankruptcy? Actually, hold
on. There's definitely in Canada versions of bankruptcy where
you get to keep your home. That exists in the States, right?
where your home is is uh is pushed out of your actual bankruptcy.
That's like a type of bankruptcy, right? There's a certain chapter
of bankruptcy that um that you can file that keeps your home
out of it. But regardless,
I do believe that
man, it's it's quite difficult. And then I don't even know how
do you what's the cheapest you can go through that litigation
cuz what if Ethan doesn't like what do you do? You're just fine
after that. Oh well, maybe she didn't want to do that. I don't
know why she didn't want to do that. I think she owns a bar as
well though, right? I think her sister runs a bar. Is that not
That's the Casey lore, right? That her sister runs like a bar
and she paid for it with her Twitch earnings early on.
Oh, Chapter 11's just Oh, I see what you're saying. No, no, no.
There is like a type of bankruptcy. I mean, you'd be you probably
I think the thing is is you probably still have to pay back Ethan
Klein in some way. I don't know. M just told me to rack up debt
in uh and settle it for 30% or so. I'm currently in phase one
with 90k debt. Yeah, debt maxers. Anyway, I So again, in the
in the denim situation where Denims doesn't have money, she would
probably have to settle. She'd probably have to do some like
this or she could easily have to do like this. And Ethan is actively
suing her. Who she who did an actual ethical reaction or what
he refers to as an ethical reaction. The exact reasons he didn't
want to go after like or sorry, the exact
differentiating factors for going after XQC
um that exist. Sorry, I said this totally wrong. One second.
Denims cannot be differentiated from somebody like XQC
uh in a negative way. Basically, the the pretext Ethan does to
do this is he says, "Well, actually her she stated her intention
to siphon views, right?" So, you'd have to assume Ethan thinks
she intended to siphon views. He's already said that XQC, Ethan
Klein has said XQC intends to siphon views when he uses the same
thumbnail as the original video, reacts to it the same day, and
uploads it the same day, and barely adds any commentary. Right?
So he knows XQC intends. Okay. So he believes both XQC and DMS
intend to siphon views, right?
No, even unless you're a [__] stated intent doesn't
matter. Okay. It's whether or not you siphon views. So Ethan
basically is arguing that the true differentiating factor between
Denims and XQC is Denim's going, "If you like that video and
not giving a view to the original guy, it doesn't matter at all,
even less. You're you're just wrong. You're you're like totally
wrong on the fair use on like the morality of it. You're totally
wrong. And by the way, uh, given her statements, I don't even
think you can argue that she was stating intent to siphon because
it's only after the fact, right?
There is no stated intent to siphon. It's after the fact that
she says, "If you enjoyed not giving views to that terrible video,
blah blah blah blah blah." Right? So, I don't even think you
have that.
So, Ethan Klein is basically arguing that that that comment is
what makes Denim's evil, not whether or not she'd actually cite
it. If she just shut her if she just shut her stupid yap. Okay.
If she just shut her stupid app, then actually siphoning the
views would be totally fine. Be totally fine. That's Ethan Klein's
argument. It's insane. >> Oh god. Do Do you guys know who
I'm talking about? There was another guy that is friends with
Hassan.
I think he has like a beard. He's um he's like a taller like
not skinny but more slender kind of person. And he said something
about Asmin Gold recently that was like whatever whatever um
whatever beef you have with some someone and however odious I
personally find Asmin cold Asmin Golds takes to be
uh from time to time.
There is such a thing as taking it way too far. Bro, there is
such a this person here. Did you guys see this?
Uh, wait. Surely Hutch will disavow this in all cases, right?
Going after people's family is totally morally wrong. You should
never do that. It's actually always wrong to go after somebody's
family members, right?
>> Asmin Gold, salutations.
And again, RIP to your dad. So sad that he had to that he had
to pass away knowing that he left behind a piece of unlike you.
Godamn. >> Wait, that's Hold on. >> He failed right
there, my man. >> Wait, that's not even talking. Okay,
that's like a slightly talking [__] This is actually
so much more tame than I thought.
Bro, who
who's pretending that this is different than saying your parents
must be embarrassed of you? Your parents failed raising you.
You understand that's an indictment of like them primarily. Yes.
And people say that [__] all the time. It's like
a common saying that people say.
Is it the fact that he's using different pronouns? He's using
He uses like the proper noun for Asmin Gold. I don't even I don't
know what the what's the
>> I'm sure your dad didn't have a lot of failures in his
life, but you are. Wait.
Oh, your dad seemed pretty awesome. He must not had very many
failures in his life, but you're one of them. >> One big
old failure. And you can say, "But I got money and I have an
audience." Yeah. That's just more people that see how much of
a piece of [__] you are. Like you've exposed your
dad's failure to the whole world. Like his
whatever you think of Asthma Gold, his dad just died
like a month ago
from pancreatic cancer.
Like you don't actually have to invoke people's
dead parents that way. Like it's just I even if your critique
of Asmin Gold is correct, you know,
you I feel like you take away from that critique by Wow. It's
uh it's like it's totally disgusting that the guy these all these
people all draft their political takes off of, right, does basically
wait the same thing? How is this not the same thing? Maybe he
killed himself because of how he couldn't handle because he couldn't
handle how you are.
I understand understand you have to like virtue signal in both
directions, right? That the Milhouse guy's take on Asmin Gold's
dad is like infinitely less offensive than this. Yes. Like infinitely
less offensive.
By the way, I don't even care about this. It's whatever. I do
think it's really funny that he virtue signals about people making
fun of him being a terrible parent, right? He, oh, they're bringing
my son into it. It's so crazy. And then he does this is a little
goofy, right? I think that's a little goofy. But overall, whatever.
It's a joke. Who
But both are bad. No, they're not both bad. I mean, they're not
both bad. If you if you're think one is funny, you can't say
they're both bad, right?
You can't you can't be okay. You can say they're both bad, maybe
in a world, but that's just not the online content creation space.
If you're if you're watching me and you think both are bad, you're
probably wrong. You're probably like inconsistent.
Because I don't know why you would watch me and the jokes I make
and then go actually this is totally inexcusable. I say I don't
like it. Like I don't I don't like when people go after people's
family. Although this one's not as bad, right? It's like the
guy's tweeting about his his brother in support of like the Venezuelan
boats getting blown up, right? I think that's pretty stupid.
And I'm like, okay, you're going to use him as a shield for that?
You you're going to use him as a shield? Well, I'm going to attack
that shield. Okay, I think this one is pretty bad. No, no, it's
not. But I'm just saying that obviously
Hutch doesn't have like a huge problem with people just making
fun of other people's family.
Okay. But this one, no, you're going to use it as a shield and
and talk about how you can blow up Venezuelan boats. Yeah. [__]
it off.
This one is worse. Wait, did he do he did a worse one? Wait,
what? I'm just saying that like
Oh, yeah. No, no, no. The I'm not going to talk about Dusty's
kids. It's weird how there's a pattern of people in that community
children. He's got like a real
these guys really just likes kids for some reason. Him food shops
they're like they're that's how they connected was just overly
girls very bizarre behavior by leaning into this like edge lord.
It's just so cruel, you know.
Was it a month? I was thinking two or maybe it was a couple months.
I'm not sure. I mean, it was pretty recently within the last
couple months.
Um,
you don't actually have to do that. And I'm well aware that Asminold
himself, I think, is he can be brutal,
but man, Asminold is Asminold's going to lose most of his protections
at this point. Okay. I think when Casey did it, Asminold didn't
deserve it. I'll be real. He was a video game streamer. He was
kind of like a an incel, like a a post gamer gate incel, but
like he wasn't that bad. All right. He didn't deserve it back
then. At this point, he's he's basically just going like, "Yes,
I am the evil super villain of the internet. Everybody, I'm going
I'm going after everybody now." Okay. I think now he's going
to lose some of his protections. But he probably felt like he
didn't have the beginning. >> You don't have to take it
that far. Um,
the internet ruined people. They no longer have filters and don't
realize thoughts can stay inside the head. And I think that social
media kind of rewards people not having a filter.
which is just really bad behavior.
>> You see the latest numbers that came out, like employment
numbers, I'm sure they're disastrous.
>> People are like, "Oh, what a savage." You get kind of
rewarded for it. You get social capital for for going like really
ham, but then you get conditioned
from your audience who rewards you for that type of behavior.
So, you kind of get psychologically conditioned.
to just go super hard
every time.
And this is all stuff that
would not be happening were it not for the internet
it's just
it's just not I I just this is not a way to be Do you guys realize
that like the internet kind of makes people bad sometimes? You
guys ever thought about how social media changed people? You
guys ever thought about that? Sometimes I think social media
changed people. I've thought that as a as a grown-up, as an adult.
Um, all elite memes with $5. So, son's audience is like 50% of
the reason I left his community and became liberal.
They're even more.
Who's watching Hutch at this point? Bro, I'm like I'm operating
at like 2.1 Hutches at the moment. I didn't get enough sleep
again and I can just tell already. We're like We're like 2 hours
into this stream. I'm already just misspeaking constantly.
I've I've really been operating like four hours of sleep a day
for the past 3 days, 4 days. It's not >> hinge behind closed
doors uh closed doors in Discords. It's a Wait, you're a former
leftist. I thought you were a former MAGA person. Thank you for
the $5. Um Ahsoka Bun, thank you so much for 30 shekels.
IMO Casey's apology sounds scripted. >> I recognize that
name from somewhere >> because she just wants to [laughter]
>> Sorry. Uh knowers recognize that name from somewhere.
She says what she needs to love how feminists like Hassan assume
Casey is too dumb.
>> It's just Klein mind control. Wait, I'm a little confused
by that. I felt like the f the the those two sentences I felt
like contradicted cuz you said the apology sounds scripted, but
then you
um
like feminists like Hassan assume she's being mind controlled.
Oh, Klein mind controlled. Um yeah, I don't know. That's a little
confusing to me. I mean, oh, okay. Okay.
I Hold on. I Hold Hold on. These are different. These are That
was Missy, so these are different. Okay. There's a lot of hate
watchers for Hutch, by the way. Kathy's watching. Missy's watching.
There's a lot of big hate watching market for Hutch. It seems
>> assume she's being mind control. >> I thought
I thought the Missy comment was somebody saying um like after
Oh, well, no, it's technically not mind control. It's financial
corion, but it's she's just being honest. >> Oh, Klein
mind controlled. Um yeah, I don't know. That's a little confusing
to me. I mean, yeah, very obviously it's I I reasonably confident
that this was uh you know, this statement was agreed upon by
both parties. We'll put it that way. I I got to say like I am
I am glad that this person will not become financially destitute.
I thought her behavior along with are you? I don't think you
get to say that. It's so up.
Oh man, I'm really glad that she will she was willing to totally
forgo her pride. She was willing to be completely financially
coerced into the statement and then she gets to keep her house.
It's like, dude, you don't get to say that. You don't get to
you don't get to
make conditional somebody's like right to survive or somebody's
ability to survive and then go, "Oh, I'm glad she's gonna get
to survive."
It's It just It's all so weird. How do people say it? I'm so
glad that she gave up her autonomy. Okay, dude. Like to me, I'll
be real.
To me,
there's not a very significant difference between this statement
and Ethan just asking Casey to go and spread her ass open and
take a picture of that and put it on the internet. Hey Casey,
gape your ass open and take a picture and post it on your Twitter
and then I'll drop the lawsuit.
What is the tangible difference between these things? No, no,
no. It's like totally coerced behavior. she would never engage
in otherwise. It's being completely financially coerced out of
her. Why are you saying it's okay just because it's like a it's
like a statement she wouldn't want to give. I don't see the
Well, one makes me feel icky and the other makes me feel good.
Like I'm I'm just telling you it's like you're coercing speech.
I think coerced speech is disgusting.
And it's coming from a guy who's meant to be giving his opinions
on the internet. Who's coercing this speech? Who's going actually
just admit that you lost in the drama? Say you lost to me in
the drama. Say Hassan lost. It's It's just disgusting, dude.
>> Uh, all the other creators that piled
>> You You guys are totally fine with Casey having her
soul gaped, but having But just showing her her her gaped, that's
apparently too far. Oh my god. This apparently just gross and
wild and unheard of. But but having her soul totally gaped open
like that, totally fine. That's totally Yep. That's fine. That's
okay. That's cool. That's very
>> Going for the CPS thing.
Wait, am I slandering her? Did she pile on to the CPS thing?
>> Oh my god. Hutch factchecking. No way.
Okay, let's go to the next part. The next part is
right here. The denim tweet. This apology which I can only assume
was [laughter] somehow forced this apology which I can only assume
was somehow forced to extract a settlement was painful to listen
to. [laughter]
>> I see why Hush Okay, Hush can sometimes be funny. Okay,
I like the I like the voice
was painful to listen to. >> Oh, never mind. He's doing
a a voice modulator. Oh, weak weak touch. It is absurd and ironic
that Ethan accuses Hassan of being a puppeteer.
>> How did you Hutch made fun of a lot of gay dudes in
high school? Okay, he was Oh my god, this suck is
while laring as a comic book villain in this way. While it is
unfortunate that Ethan appears to have been able to exert control
over her in this way, I am happy that Caseyron was given the
opportunity to minimize the harm to her family, avoid the risk
of losing her home, and move on from Ethan's lawsuit.
I want to make several things clear. My trial date is 102626.
Likely Froggen.
>> She hold on, hold on, wait, wait, wait. >> And
I look forward to beating Ethan in court while Casey and likely
Froggen have caved
the Ethan Klein. >> Don't do the thing. Don't do the thing.
Is this not all po dude?
All of all of these things that we all know about if you're following
this at all. All of these things that we all know about. can't.
It was obviously Frogggin's like judgment from the very beginning.
She stopped playing games immediately. She was immediately like
this was the first thing we we saw, right? Everybody's like,
"Oh, Froggen's clearly settling." We knew that weeks ago, months
ago, maybe she's clearly settling. Like, she's just going to
she's going to spend as little money on this as possible. She's
going to take her lumps and settle and be done, right?
We've all known that. What What is the leak coming out here?
She was obviously trying to settle the whole time. She was never
ever going to put up an actual legal fight. She was just gonna
settle. Damn. [clears throat] Damn,
dude. I
the the the Ethan Klein the H3 ball fondling minstrel show has
got to go. It's got to go. It's got to be done. We got to be
done with this. Okay, we got to we got to be done as a as a internet
society. Okay, we have to be done with
Oh my god. Did they just le did she just leak that is going to
settle? Oh, did he did he just He probably did watch the Dioro
stream, didn't he? Almost certainly he watched the Dioro stream.
It's just the Dioro stream beat forbe right now. He just He watches
the Dioro stream at night. He He fires up his stream. He's like,
I could just say all the same things. Let's go. >> She
tossed them under the bus, bro. >> Oh, wait. It's dumber.
Is Is it dumber somehow?
Is it Is it somehow dumber? It's somehow more dumb.
I want to say dumber, but more dumb. What her explicit Didn't
she explicitly
I I'm glad they're getting out of this situation. I because like
I don't know what their cases is is, but like I have enough money
that I can pursue it >> Why? What's with all the thing
up here? Like I'm so glad she was able to move on from her life
and d also she caved, you know? Like
it's so disingenuous. Like I don't understand. This is crazy
to me, man. This is Wait, she's saying they caved because they
did. She could have said settled. She could have used some slightly
less negative word, but she is saying it's bad to cave to Ethan
Klein over this. He is a totally like he is a child. He's throwing
a childlike tantrum right now and using throwing his financial
might around his financial weight around to get his way. He's
just throwing a tantrum, right? She even says, which is a decision
I doubt they've made lightly, as in it's a bad decision, but
I doubt they made it lightly. Like, it's clearly a thing that
is going to [__] them over, right? Uh, it is not
an option for me because it would set a precedent that endangers
the financial security of any streamer that creates reaction
content. This is not true. This is actually just wrong. I hope
he at least points out that that's
This is this is so crazy to me.
I think these people just exist in their own kind of like
their own little bubble where they're like the kings and queens
of their bubble and they just get all this validation from their
audience and such.
And then they end up saying stuff like this with no self-awareness.
>> How do any Oh my god. Hold on. How do any DJers Did
I just have a brain blast? Maybe somebody said this cuz it's
all the Destiny community is all over this, right? It's all over
Hutch's stream. But
is there any possible way you could say what they say about Destiny's
case? Okay. Why is Pixie suing Destiny when she was harmed way
more by the guy who did the the did why? Like why she's suing
Destiny?
Why is she not suing Solo? Why is she not suing the guy who leaked
the images, right? Oh, she that guy did way more harm. That's
the actual harmful party. And then they support this thing where
Ethan suing these people when he's obviously been harmed far
more by people like XQC and Asmin Gold. If he wants to make an
argument of harm, that's where the harms come from, right? How
could you make the harm argument, oh, you can only you should
sue, you're actually disingenuous unless you're suing the most
harmful person. They actually maintain that with Destiny and
his cases. No.
How could any of those same people
uh whatever I
I say that like like actually that connection and that clear
um that clear double standard would actually change any of their
minds. I never mind. Never mind. It wouldn't change any of their
minds. I shouldn't even think about it. We're moving on. >> Like
when you say
>> uh Ethan has So in terms of bad reactions, XQC barely
added any runtime, right? He barely had he had barely any runtime
to the thing. And then he copied Ethan's thumbnail and he just
uploaded it in full, right? Got way more views, siphoned way
more views from Ethan by doing this, right? Denim's barely got
her [__] to YouTube. It went to YouTube way later.
It got like 8,000 views. But it's fine. It doesn't matter if
there's if, by the way, that's not a good argument. You shouldn't
you shouldn't be able to argue, oh, you have to h you have to
sue the most harmful person. But people do argue that on the
internet a lot. Very interesting. While Casey and likely Froggen
have caved to Ethan Klein, it just totally invalidates all of
this. Like all of this is just obviously, right? You're not happy
that she moved on with her life, you know? You're not happy that
she no longer has the stress of the lawsuit. You just
Dude, this is somebody makes a decision that you know is painful
for them, but ultimately is better for their life. You say, "I'm
happy for them, but I wish I like I think it's bad that they
were forced to do that." Right?
>> Behaved. Like, you didn't have to you didn't have to
phrase it this way. You could have phrased it a different way.
You didn't have to do that. You're taking a dig at them by doing
that. And the other thing, too, is like she's very obviously
positioning herself as like, "They might have caved, but I'm
going to bravely soldier on." Like, it's all very
and uh self arandizing, you know? Hey, hey, um, this person's
in a legal case and they want to try to fund raise for that legal
case. It's very shocking that they're trying to fund raise for
that legal case. That they're using new news coming out to fund
raise for that legal case. Isn't it, guys? Isn't that really
shocking how she's like making a statement on the in the wake
of Casey's statement, right? That's going to get into a huge
drama cycle. It's very shocking to me that she would go and try
to fund raise off of that. Isn't that like really disingenuous
when she needs to fund raise to actually engage in this lawsuit
against somebody who's far richer, has far more money than her,
right? Isn't it very shocking that she would fundra for that
off of this news that somebody else settled that they were financially
pressured into settling and and making a statement that, by the
way, didn't have very much to do with copyright?
Huh. That's so crazy. That's so weird. What a what a disingenuous
duplicitous lying. I'm the real fighter here. Yeah, that's exactly
what she's doing. Um,
settling like this is not an option for me. It's not an option
for me because it would set a precedent that endangers the financial
security
of any streamer that creates reaction content.
If you create react
if you create content that involves commentating on videos on
Twitch or enjoy consuming reaction content, you should be on
my side. If you don't believe me, please read ahead and let me
convince you.
I watched and reacted to Ethan's highly anticipated content nuke
shortly after it aired. Make no mistake, my coverage more than
doubled Ethan's video in length. Ethan's video spanned roughly
104 minutes. I spent 230 minutes reacting to, critiquing,
and commenting on his video and the content in it.
>> Will he comment on this? >> During which I paused
210 times.
This means I added
120% of the run time in the commentary.
on average pausing every 30 seconds to add 36 seconds of commentary.
This commentary length is substantially more than Asmin Gold
XQC
or any of the many other streamers and YouTubers
that watched the content nuke in full. Is she she gonna even
address the um the fact that she specifically told her audience
like watch it here so you don't give him a view? >> She
is actually. That's so that's so kind for Hutch to like pre-rape
himself like that. Can you imagine? Can you imagine being this
guy? He just like totally pre-rapes himself like that. She's
actually about to address that in the next paragraph. Oh my god.
Thank you, Hush. >> But that was the big thing. That [clears throat]
was the thing. That was the uniting feature or action among all
>> Okay. No, it wasn't. Unless you think that stated intent
matters more than actual intent, right? That's the you have to
live in that world where you saying where where you believe this
on a moral and legal principle, okay? That if I say I want to
hit you in the face, I'm going to hit you in the face, but I
don't hit you in the face. That is worse than hitting you in
the face. That like if I say I'm going to hit you in the face,
hutch, and then don't. I just walk away. That is a worse action
than just punching you in the dome. Okay, I'd probably break
my hand on that big beautiful bald dome of yours. Okay, but apparently
that is worse.
Nobody lives in that world. Nobody believes that. Nobody thinks
you think that. Shut the [__] up. >> That Ethan
initiated litigation with to my recollection. Am I remembering
this correctly? I'm pretty sure Caseyron said that. Pretty sure
Frogan said that. >> What's the actual Hold on. What's
the actual linking thing? What's the actual leaking linking thing?
Well, it's actually that these people all talk about Ethan Klein,
right? That these people all Ethan Klein perpetually. That's
that's the actual linking element, the the common denominator
between these three people. Um,
Denim said that, right? All three of them said,
"Make sure you watch it here so you don't give that view." I
don't know what they said specifically, but is she even going
to even like mention that? Um,
as we know, Ethan decided not to sue Asmin Gold, XQC,
or anyone anyone other than the three of us. Wait, hold on. Let's
make some Let's make some predictions. Is she going to say like,
is it because we were supporters of Palestine? They love >> I
mean, no. No, he Ethan is not suing supporters of Palestine who
reacted to his content nuke. He's suing people who talk [__]
about him >> of saying that.
Ethan specifically targeted women who advocate for Palestine.
I can't tell you how many times.
>> I saw a taste like that.
>> Intentionally tried to deprive him of revenue and you
said yourself that you did. This notion is frivolous. Friv
this notion is frivolous and is a fabrication. What?
Uh Ethan claims he is pursuing his claim against me only because
of some claimed malicious intent on my part. There are two statements
that Ethan falsely claims demonstrate my intent along with his
conspiracy theory about collusion with Reddit moderators, none
of whom I have ever communicated with. The first statement is
my response to a chat message. I read it out, quote, "We're relying
on you to stay live so we don't have to give the nuke views."
End quote. And then replied, quote, "Yeah, I'm going to stream
it since he's confirmed it's coming out today. I'm going to stream
it." End quote. I hope this is self-evident, but it would be
bizarre for me to take that opportunity to bring attention to
this group of people and how they actually should watch his video
on his channel. It isn't my place. I don't care. and making a
big deal out of it. We only encourage the zealatry that Ethan
is a >> No, no, Denims. Don't you understand that principles?
Listen,
forget about my principles on DMCA. Forget about my principles
on compelling speech via the legal system. Okay? Compelling any
speech via the legal system. Forget any of those positions, Denims.
You have to adhere to your principles when it's hard for you.
I don't have to do it when it's hard for me. You have to adhere
to your principles when it's hard to you or hard for you. Okay?
You need to say, "No, go watch it on his channel." You need to
do that, not me. I'm >> upset about. I immediately acknowledged
that I was going to react to it. >> Sorry, I'm I'm taking
swings at the >> drawing a broader narrative based on a
chat message, not right is delusional. Why would you read it
out loud then? Like, how does that make any sense?
>> Like, why would you read it out loud? Like, if somebody
says like, >> um, oh, yeah, thank god you're live. So,
we don't give him a view and you're like, "Oh, no, yeah, I'm
going to stream it." The logical inference is that you're like,
"Yeah, no, I'll do that for you. That's what I'm doing." That's
just the obvious logical inference. Relax really says, "Who gives
a [__] This is so stupid. I'm sorry. This is straight
up entertainment to me. I don't know about you guys, but
the second statement is a throwaway shill comment I said after
the video before signing off. Quote, "Well, guys, if you enjoyed
not giving any views to that terrible video, follow, subscribe,
throw a prime if you like my content." End quote. As an aside,
this statement is factual. Almost certainly if someone watched
my coverage, they had no interest in watching Ethan's video without
the addition of critical commentary and never would have.
Regardless, this statement does not characterize my intent. At
most, you can say, "This is a mean-spirited comment in poor taste.
Making a joke like this is too far and that Ethan Klein deserves
more respect. We can agree to disagree. Hang on. What did she
just say? At most you can say this is a means for you to comment
in more taste. Making a joke like this is too far and that Ethan
deserves and deserves more respect. We can agree to disagree.
>> Okay. He will he contend. Will he contend with any of
this? He's just read it. He's not contended in any way. >> Well
guys, if you enjoyed not giving any views to that terrible video,
follow, subscribe, and throw prime in my content. I mean, I I'm
not listen I don't pretend to know anything about copyright law,
but that feels pretty
Does Hutch know about like causality? Does he know about like
the way time flows? How can he start? How can he start or sorry,
how can anyone start trying to intending to siphon views? How
can they start siphoning views by stating afterwards? Oh, I guess
if you were here, I guess you watch with me instead of him. One
is a statement of fact. the other if you say it before if you're
like oh yeah yeah I don't get everybody you know to come watch
here instead of the if she did something like that then maybe
you have the argument on intent which by the way doesn't matter
still right it like yeah she said it feels uh what is it meanspirited
that's malicious yes that is mean-spirited absolutely oh well
that guy guess you watch it here that guy
that guy yeah it's malicious it's mean spirited she says as much
right here but it's not uh it's not a statement of intent use
is protected not giving any views to that terrible video. Follow,
subscribe, and throw prime in my content. I mean, I I'm not Listen,
I I don't pretend to know anything about copyright law, but that
feels pretty
Fair use is protected. Obviously, that's long been established
that fair use is a thing. There are protections
if you add, you know, commentary if you meaningfully transform
the content.
Okay. So, are we going to engage with the broad part of the the
broad post? She says, I meaning I meaningfully engaged. I transformed
the content. My reaction was longer than many other people. Even
a lot of the people who criticized me, my reaction was longer.
I, by the way, I'm not going to say anything about the accuracy
or how good her commentary was. I don't know. I didn't watch
the whole thing. I watched a good chunk of it or sorry, I watched
a good chunk of the beginning. She was definitely commenting
quite a bit. She added a lot of runtime. Uh, the commentary was
almost certainly far better than many of her contemporaries.
Okay. Right. She saw that as like her audition. She probably
saw the numbers going up. She was trying to pause and inject
her opinion and and make it like her thing. Right. Obviously,
does it need to be good commentary in that way? Yeah, I I'm just
saying I'm not making a comment on it. Like, I don't care. Doesn't
matter, right?
so, that is meaningfully transforming the content. So, why are
you saying, "Well, very useless protective. You meaningfully
transform it." Like, are you just agreeing with her entirely
that Ethan Klein is totally disingenuously suing her? >> But
if you're going out here and you're saying stuff like, and it's
it's the combination of these two things that are not great,
you know? Like first like reading out this comment, I don't know
how she thinks she can kind of snake like squirm out of this
because this is just so obvious. Okay, then make the argument.
Literally just argue that it's obvious.
AJ, I saw that Lauren Chen is back. What the happened there?
I thought she went to prison for the Russian. No, she didn't
go to prison. Um, she wasn't even Wait, the indictment we saw
wasn't even against her. Why would you think she went to prison?
Are you
Are you like totally What? Sorry, I I shouldn't be mean to you.
I I apologize if I was mean to you. Um, why would you think she's
going to prison? I don't get it. The indictment you saw was for
the Russian people who are running Tenant, not for her. What?
What are you doing, man? Anyway, what? Hold on. We're about to
listen to Hutch's Hutch is going to lay out for us
exactly
how he believes this proves her intent. I'm I'm psyched. I'm
psyched. I'm psyched.
>> I don't know how she thinks she can kind of snake like
squirm out of this because this is just so obvious.
It's so obvious. Lay it out for me. >> The person says,
"We're allowing you to stay live so we don't have to give the
nuke views." And then she goes, "Yeah, yeah, no. I'm I'm going
to stream it." And then you >> That is an acknowledgement
of the market that exists that doesn't want to watch it through
Ethan alone. They want to watch it with critical commentary.
That is that is literally you are citing proof of a parallel
market that exists. Her not creating a market replacement. You
are citing proof of that. Actually, that is what you're citing
proof of Hutch. And you combine that with like if you enjoyed
not giving it.
>> Okay, so she acknowledges that secondary market, but
she made no plans. She did not, you know, she did not plan to
do this. She went live. She acknowledged somebody in chat who
said something. She didn't set anything up. There are no plans
that went out.
Don't worry about it, Alex. I'm sorry. I was I was rude to you.
I I should be nicer to people. It's fine.
He He did nothing. He basically just read it. He read it again
and went, "It's obvious, huh? It's obvious." He She Okay. What
she did was she she read a chat message and then and then she
was mean. I think case closed, guys. She read a chat message
and she was also mean. It's over.
Any views? I mean, this is just so malicious. It's just so on
its face.
Super malicious. But I hold on. This is confusing to me. like
the last sentence of this the last two sentences of this um paragraph
confused me because she says at most you can say that this is
a mean-spirited comment in poor taste making a joke like this
is too far and that Ethan Klein deserves more respect. Now, when
she says that, it's
>> so I I just tell you what the argument she's going to
make is, okay,
I'm just acknowledging the secondary market that exists for watching
this content that like there is a there's a market for this this
influencer of people who dislike him and want critical content.
And I'm acknowledging that that market exists. I'm not attempting
to create a parallel market or sorry, I'm not ex I'm not attempting
to create a market replacement. I'm saying there is a second
market. I'm acknowledging it. I'm thanking them for their support.
seems like she wants that to be a part of her defense. She's
saying it wasn't, you know, it wasn't meant to be malicious.
She's saying like at most you can say it's a mean-spirited comment
in poor taste. So it seems like she's saying like, well that,
you know, it's not the malicious like I'm trying to
Okay, I have to help Hutch out here. You're trying to prove intent.
Sometimes other things outside of the the like what leads up
to something can prove intent. Sometimes. Sometimes. But man,
it's hard. It's very difficult to look at things that happen
after the fact and say that they prove something about the intent
of an act that came before. Okay, it's very difficult. It's basically
mind readading. You need a lot of stuff there. Okay.
Hutch thinks malicious equals mean. Well, hold on. It's a malicious
statement as in she doesn't like Ethan. It's not maliciously
creating a a market replacement. It's not intentionally attempting
to siphon views. That's not what it is, right? So to me, if you
wanted to say she had a she made a malicious attempt to siphon
views, you would need I think some sort of planning, some sort
of pre-planning, if you could get, let's say hypothetically she
did collude with the Reddit to she like wanted her name up at
the top and she wanted people to direct to her content, that
would be I think that would make the case, right?
But what he's doing is he's saying, well, she acknowledged this
person who asked if if they were going to if they were going
to stream it. She said yes. right now. That person said something
about, you know, I don't want to give I don't want to give any
views to the video. I think she references that person at the
end. If she made no other
man, I don't know. I think that's pretty tough. Not that this
will matter, by the way. Not that this it will come down to whether
or not she created a market replacement, which by the way, this
is all actually arguing in my opinion in Ethan Klein's favor,
okay? Because her stated intent, that's weak as what's actually
strong is the idea that she might have created a market replacement.
She streamed it at the same time. She streamed it live. She streamed
it to a lot of people that those facts are going to be hard to
overcome.
I'm actually doing a better job of arguing in Ethan's favor than
they are. They're they're arguing in some totally direction that
makes no sense whatsoever, right?
And I'm just like, no, no, no. Like, you could probably argue
she created a market replacement in some way. She's acknowledging
a parallel market, like a secondary market that she's trying
to garner, but it's very easy to argue that she might be buy
streaming at the same time while it's live trying to create a
second, like a a market replacement. There is no way to reasonably
argue that 100% of viewers were that market. Uh, you don't have
to do 100%, Zanali. Why would you have to do 100%.
That's not true.
That's just not true at all.
Doesn't have to be 100%. I don't even know what the percentage
would have to be, right? that you're creating a market replacement.
How much of their market you'd have to siphon away to create
a market replacement. I would imagine it doesn't have to be a
lot. >> Maliciously steal views. It's that it was a mean-spirited
joke. But then she says at the end, but we can agree to disagree.
So like doesn't this undermine that defense? Okay. So, but you
don't think that. She's saying like at most you can say this
is a mean spirited comment, but then she says like we can agree
to so she doesn't think that. So like I you know, so what is
the defense? I don't really understand. Okay. So you say like
okay, you don't agree that it was a mean spirited joke and it
went too far. So then what do you think it was then? I don't
really understand. like, you know, um, Snow Source says yes,
she's playing word games that this was likely vetted by her lawyers.
I mean, I would hope so, right? But like, I don't know. To me,
that feels like she's undermining the defense a little bit there.
There was a 100% chance this admission of guilt is going into
the lawsuit, by the way. Good job, Denim's genius. I just like,
what is her defense, right? Like,
she tried to defend herself here by saying like, "Oh, you just
misinterpreted the sequence of events up here." But oh, I guess
this is
is Hutch like is he actually I can't tell if it's Dude,
this is another key element to being an Ethan defender. Okay,
you have to be performatively baffled by reality AT ALL TIMES.
WHAT?
HUH? [screaming]
No way. What?
What?
No. No way. What, guys? Huh? No way. Did she really do? No. I
What is her What is she doing? How is this possible? What is
going on
at all times?
Oh my. Huh? Huh? Huh? What? What? Huh? It's just all the time.
I have no idea what's happening. This is her defense. Hold on.
She says, "As an aside, this statement is factual. Almost certainly
if someone watched my coverage, they had no interest in watching
Ethan's video without the addition of critical commentary and
never would have. Regardless, the statement does not characterize
my intent. At most you can say that it is a mean spirited comment.
>> She as she literally says precisely what her defense
is. It's in a sentence.
This statement does not characterize my intent. At most you could
say it is a mean-spirited comment.
If someone watched my coverage, they had no interest in watching
Ethan's with video without the addition of critical commentary
and never would have. That is the argument. I did not create
a market replacement because that is a secondary market. It is
a parallel market that does not include Ethan's fans and it never
would. What?
What is What is this? Can you lead a Can you start a sentence
with at? I didn't even think you could start an English sentence
with the letter A.
What is this
A a common. A common. What do I do
How do I read?
Wait, what is happening with this guy?
What What is he doing? what he's doing is I think you just have
to basically say you don't understand anything so that you don't
I guess have to engage with the arguments they're making right
and he kind of does after the fact if you if listen far be it
for me to say that you can't performatively go oh my god this
person's I have no idea what they're trying to do and then go
oh but I actually do and and follow it up but you you should
contend with the actual arguments right >> I mean
I think very clearly her her intent was to to you know >> dude
this is there's there's something to be said for arguing with
this kind of golem. Okay.
I just think that clearly a reasonable person would say that
I'm correct. I just think that very clearly it's obvious on its
face that in every reasonable person's mind in the real world
that I am correct. >> Hey, hang on a second. Hang on. Hang
on.
No, hang on. There's no way her lawyer helped her with this because
this doesn't make any sense. There's a pretty glaring contradiction
here. Okay. >> Oh, let's go. Hold on. He's actually contending.
He's actually contending. She says down here in this in in this
paragraph, she says, almost certainly if someone watched my coverage,
they had no interest in watching Ethan's video without the addition
of critical commentary. But then literally one paragraph before,
she references a chatter who says, quote, "We're relying on you
to stay live so we don't have to give the nuke views." This person
is very clearly indicating that they do want to see what was
in the content
>> They are saying they might watch it if she doesn't stay
live. >> Excuse me. Also, that person. Okay, hold on, hold
on, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait. So,
wait. Does that be does it become incumbent on Denims not to
stream it the second person asks? This person asked the question,
should she lie? Should she say, "I can't comment on whether or
not they'll view it." What is the What is the other conduct she
could do? Not stream the content nuke.
The thing she would do automatically as a streamer, massive new
pieces of piece of content drops that criticizes you directly.
You can watch it live. I thought, didn't Ethan do that with Idubbbz?
Didn't Ethan have a Idubbbz video dropped live while the H3 podcast
was going and didn't he react to it live? Oh, wait,
man. I'm trying to think of like when this happened.
When did Ethan announce his lawsuits? And how long after the
Idubbbz video was past the point where it could be registered
with the Library of Congress did he do so? Did he wait to file
those lawsuits until Idubbbz could no longer do the same thing
to him?
Oh, that would be an interesting timeline to go look at, wouldn't
it? Like if he if he was like two days later he announces the
lawsuits, like the second after Idubbbz has lost his chance to
go back and register his own video. But also, I'm actually not
100% sure that's the correct timeline.
Um, like if if Ethan watched the whole thing, but that's what
I'd heard was that Idubbbz dropped a video on Ethan and Ethan
just watched it live immediately. He just immediately turned
it on and was like, "Let's go. Criticism for me. Let's do it."
I'm not a lawyer, but that seems like
a pretty silly obvious contradiction. >> I Why? Hold on.
Why though? Can you tell me if you are only interested in the
content nuke and not the critical commentary, what do you gain
from watching Denims,
right? What do you gain? I actually don't know.
I have like like honestly this is my hypothetical. If I just
reproduced Ethan's thing, but like the the content nuke, but
there was just nails on a chalkboard going the whole time,
would that be would it really compete with the content nuke directly?
Would it? I feel like it wouldn't
like and that's just core to what Denims is doing here. That's
what I assume. Like, dude, if you don't like my commentary, why
the would you watch any video I'm putting out? I pause a lot.
I talk a lot. I end up turning content that's like 15 minutes
into two hours. Why the would you ever watch that content through
me? Do 64p Russian cam rips of Avengers compete? I think they
do. They absolutely do, Zanali. But that's because there's not
a free that's that's to do with price, right? Obviously, if something
costs a certain amount of money and you create a market replacement
for free, that obviously overcomes a ton of hurdles, right? That's
a monetary hurdle. That's massive.
No, I guess the only way you could squirm out of this is if you
were just if you could if you could say that um like oh the person
was was obviously being sarcastic. Like I don't even know. But
like yeah, that that totally that comment alone and the fact
that she read it out loud and like affirmed it. I I don't know,
man. I'm not a lawyer.
Do not take legal advice for me. Um okay. I humbly request that
we take this opportunity to question Ethan's framing.
>> Isn't that the same post? Hold on. What did you ask?
God, she posts a lot. Isn't that the same post?
what >> of events and call a spade a spade. Ethan is bullying
people who said things about him he did not like and he can do
that only because he has more money than them. In doing so, at
least in his lawsuit against me, he is setting a disastrous precedent
for our corner of the internet. And my hope is that others in
our community with resources like
>> do not follow in his small footsteps. Please donate
to my legal fund. Every penny has gone exclus.
So again, that person is staying live.
I see what he's saying a little bit when he says like, "Oh, she
he's saying, "Oh, we don't want to give them views." But I don't
know if it's incumbent on Denims to say, "We want to watch it
with you more than him." Is it incumbent on Denims to say, "No,
I'm going to go offline or I'm not going to watch it when she
would normally do that." I don't know. That's a good question.
For me personally, I actually offer this to people a lot. Like
if I know a content creator, I'll say, "Hey, I can wait." When
I like when I used to react to Willy Mac videos, I actually said,
"Hey, Willy Mack,
uh, if you want me to wait a day to watch your videos, I can
do that." But I I was going to watch it now, but if you want
me to wait a day, like to let your video take off, I'm fine doing
that. And he was like, "No, no, watch it when it comes out."
Right.
But I don't know if that's like required of the streamer necessarily.
If she added a bunch of commentary, she should win the suit.
Nope. Nope. Probably not the way it works. Probably not the way
it works, man. I think the the whole point that fair use stands
on right now from a legal perspectives perspective is if you
watch a piece of content, you cut it up to use only
to use only the Yeah, you Oh, I did literally message him tonight.
If you cut you have to cut it up to use only the pieces you need.
Doing that work is what it requires to be transformative. If
you go in without the without the intent or without knowing you
can transform something, then how can you really transform it?
Right? Uh, I've said this before, but conventional wisdom is
in these spaces on fair use is not in line with the law. Yeah.
Yeah. Yeah. No, I know. Tequila Sunset. Yes. Absolutely. When
people say I'm telling you that when I talk about like ethical
reacts, quote unquote, that's basically saying that there's a
there's like this ambiguity that we all exist in right now. That's
why people don't want this lawsuit to go through, right? Because
it will it will have to settle the ambiguity. The ambiguity on
which this entire empire rests, okay? It's founded on every single
React piece of content. It's all founded on the same thing. It
all kind of goes away. Or at least the people who stream for
significant portions of the day and just watch full content pieces,
right? That whole thing kind of goes away a little
We're going to have to figure out what we're going to do here,
man. I don't know what we're going to do. I think I like reading
articles, though. I think I could easily go and do um news and
politics streams, and I would like that a lot. And then just
grab drama clips as we go. I think we could easily do that. Um
yeah. So anyway, but what you should probably do for a stream,
what you would have to do now is you'd have to go and grab timestamps.
You'd have to do the thing Red Bar does where you react to time
stamps. Yes, you'd have to pre-watch everything. So it wouldn't
be reactions. It would be pre-watching um before setting up the
content and then doing it the next day. Actually might force
some streamers to just do far better content.
I know if I pre-watch stuff, it's way better. I just don't really
do it for I just don't really do it a lot.
Kind of behind the eightball sometimes, you know. Anyway, we're
I think we're basically done with Hutch's stuff here. Oh, also
like just so we're clear on the intent thing that's like quibbling.
It will it will come. It's it's really the argument is is it
worse to punch you in the face or say I'm going to punch you
in the face? Obviously saying I'm going to punch you in the face
and then punch you in the face that's bad too. But if I just
say I'm going to punch you in the face and I very intentionally
don't
feel like that's less bad than punching you in the face literally.
Force a lot of bad people to retire. Yeah, I guess
Huh. That was That was my Asmin Gold moment. Yeah, I guess so.
Yeah, I guess so. Read a chat message. Yeah, that's right. Yeah,
I guess so.
Yeah, I guess
All right, we're We've got one more Hutch time stamp and then
we're done with Hutch and we're moving on. I think we're going
to do
probably Connor Pisco after this. Probably. Probably. Probably.
Pro probably. We'll see.
Oh, the Akash Sing the Akash Sing stuff is out too. That's the
other thing. Time stamp of Connor going after Joe. Okay.
Um, I do want to watch Do we watch that first
or do I
Ah, man. I don't know. Sorry. Do we watch the time stamp first
before we go into the actual stuff? I'm going to do it. Kosh,
don't worry. I'm going to do
Let me see here. I need to grab the timestamp from Riyle's DMs.
Where is this? There it is. Barely talks about Nick Dioro's reaction.
>> Like 25 minutes into this VOD. Are you talking about
I think I'm already here, right? Yeah. No, I don't hate Hassan.
I don't I don't hate Hassan. >> Stop the cap. Stop the
cap. Please, right now. It's okay. Please, please, please, please
just spam this. Spam the emote. You got the emote. Spam it right
now. Critical cap emote needed. Okay. Critical cap support in
the chat required. Okay. It's never been more critical to support
the Jtock cap emote right now. Okay. Jesus Christ. Holy. I don't
hate Aison at all, guys. I >> I just want him like totally
>> I hate the things that people do
I hate like
negative. >> That's just hating the person. That's just
hating the person. Okay, I'm sorry. I don't hate you. I hate
everything you do. I hate everything about you. I don't hate
you. I don't hate the soul, but I hate like everything about
you, including your stupid face.
I hate
like destructive
actions and behavior,
but I generally don't hate people. Um,
I mean, listen, I'm a human being, so there's some days
I do have hatred coursing through my
Some days I have
pure vitriol just coursing through my veins. I'm a human being
like everybody else. I'm not Jesus Christ. But
on my better days, like when I'm having a good day and my head's
in the right space, I generally don't hate people.
Wow.
I don't I super sorry. We're going to move.
Hold on. I'll just speed it up. I just I have it sped down. If
I speed it up, it's not as considering what Ethan could have
done. To the extent that Ethan could have taken it with Caseyron,
she got off pretty easy if you ask me. a threeminute apology.
That's it.
He could have pursued litigation to the point where they could
have garnished part of her wages for the rest of her life. And
instead, she had to make a video saying that anti-mitism is a
growing problem in leftwing spaces, apologizing for >> talking
about AB and um what's AB's wife's name again? >> Damn
it, Lena. Is that her name? When you think about it, actually
Ethan's like a really kind person because he could have totally
destroyed Casey Trron's life and instead
instead he got what he really wanted was which was just a conceession
on a bunch of different drama.
He could have total totally destroyed her life and he didn't
he was merciful.
Wow. I actually met them. >> He didn't. By the way, just
to be clear,
what he really could have done was do the same thing everybody
else does. They don't register their stuff at the Library of
Congress and then they DMCA, right? And if the person refuses
to take it down or refuses to stop doing what they're doing,
then they get sued.
That's how it works for everybody else. That's how it has always
worked. That's how it's current it currently works on the internet.
You DMCA the person and if they keep trying to take your copyright,
you keep like pursuing it legally.
But Ethan went a different way so that he could totally maliciously
try to win drama by threatening financial ruination because he's
a [__] >> Actually met them and uh they were
very nice in person. I'm just saying that's my anecdotal experience.
Very very nice
Olivia was included in the apology not Lena. Oh, that's right.
That's right. >> See Kilo in the chat asking why Hutch
is totally fine with compelled speech on different topics. You
sue somebody for one thing, you compel their speech on another
topic. Like imagine Nicholas
How do I say this without I I can't do this without slurs, so
maybe I'll just not do it.
>> Never mind. >> Were you saying I need to um to
fast forward 25 minutes into the reading or fast forward 25 minutes
into the >> Let's say hypothetically Nicholas Dioro did
react to some full video and somebody sued him
and they got him to make a video saying,
"I'm a huge fat fsler."
Like and subscribe, guys. I'm a huge fat fler. Okay. And would
that be acceptable? Is that like a cool thing to do if they sue
him for copyright? Why the [__] would that just make
a video calling yourself all kinds of names?
Is that is that acceptable? Is that
is that cool? Is that good?
Listen, I don't like Nicholas. I don't LIKE NICHOLAS, BUT I WOULD
STILL BE AGAINST THAT. I WOULD STILL THINK that's I would still
be like, "Oh, that person's totally arranged just in a totally
malicious way. he watches one of their videos and instead of
them going and filing a DMCA claim, by the way, let's not forget
about the fact that we've opened Pandora's box for the entire
internet at this point, right? That now everybody knows about
this Library of Congress loophole and nobody talks about this
right now. Technically, anybody who reacts to my in full, I can
just go and file like a copyright claim with the Library of Congress
after the fact. I have time right after the stream. Anybody reacts
to my [__] in full at all. Okay? and I could just
go sue them
and then it's statutory damages. You would totally laugh. We
all would. Uh I might say, "Oh, I like I think it's funny it's
happening happening to him, but I would obviously be against
the person suing him, no matter who it was."
I'm sorry. That's just true.
That's how it is, man. It's why every time that people bring
up Destiny's kid, I ban them. I get rid of the message. I do
because no matter how much I hate somebody, I have certain principles.
I'm not going over the I'm not going over the line on them. That's
just how it is. That's how it's got to be. Video to get to the
reading. I assume it was because the I assume it was to get to
the reading, right? >> Oh, by the way, um Destiny is still
trying to dox people, still threatening new doces each day from
people in this community. Total psychopath, totally deranged.
Um he's going to get in terms of legal consequences what's coming
to him. I'm almost I'm almost positive. So, all she had to do
was just apologize for like a few like a three-minute apology.
Yeah, I mean she [__] that could have um that could
that could have been way worse, you know, way worse.
Lena was mentioned with AB regarding the um T8.
>> Uh we'll see. >> Charity donuts raised. >> All
right. >> How cooked it is. I'm a pessimist at heart, but
I really don't know how to see this as anything other than a
win for the troll. Yeah, he technically didn't win the legal
battle, but he got to squeeze this woman for money and then make
her read his pathetic statement. I really want you. Obviously,
we can see through this. >> Are there any are there any
reactions to this in that from that community that have been
posted yet?
Like, did Denims react to it? I I assume she's got to be a little
careful, right?
you know, she's [clears throat and snorts] got Did Denims react
to it? Cuz uh Ethan just totally disingenuously picks people
he doesn't like to sue for copyright infringement. So, she's
got to be a little careful now. Yeah, that's the chilling effect.
We don't want you
He just Oh, man. She's got to be careful. It's like her speech
is totally chilled now. Oh my god. >> Right. So, like truly,
she wouldn't be silly enough to
react to it on the stream, right? Did any Did anybody else We
We saw his songs. It was only like a fiveminute reaction, but
I don't know if there was more. Was there a longer video that
got posted? This is the funniest uh greatest hits of Crash Outs.
I mean, it's just like an unequivocal Ethan W. >> Like,
what what a resounding unequivocal Ethan W on this one. Oh, Hutch,
you sweet summer child. I'm sure she will. Surely she's not that
dumb. I'm not even saying that as a jab. Surely she's not that
dumb. Surely Dan is not that dumb that she would react to this
on stream. There's no way, right? Um top
>> that she would react to $2. I hope Ethan wins just for
the lols. Thank you so much for that, buddy. Jam with 87 months.
SP with 18 months. You're [__] bald and constantly
get [__] wrong about the NHS and its conception.
Love you anyways. Bald freak. That is very aggressive. Didn't
need to do that. I saw Mike saying this was bad for Ethan because
he looks bad. Well, I think he Well, I think he looks a little
petty. I >> I don't know why they see this as a win for
them. >> I don't know why they see this as a win for them.
Oh, I don't know. I have no
>> what did you think of Pisco? Pisco.
>> What did you think of Pisco? Pisco's take is completely
wrong. >> I saw Pisco's take. I you know he we I remember
us talking about the lawsuits and his whole thing the whole time
was that he felt like it was disingenuous that Ethan was framing
it like it was about copyright. But to me it just feels like
probably the wrong thing to focus on I guess. Uh does Hutch react
to like other people's videos, other people's streams fairly
often? Does he not see how this could be used? how Kyle Kolinsky
could go file a copyright thing with the Library of Congress
for one of his videos
and he could sue Hutch for the same thing and that Hutch's commentary
is not substantially better than what Denim's commentary is.
He is in the same precarious position Denims would be. Now he's
not doing the Casey Tron thing. Casey Trump was that's the easy
one. Okay, but he is his commentary is not better than denims
and he would be in the same position.
>> Alleged Ethan Klein settlement with the Casey Tron super
spot. Thank you so >> There's there's literally nothing
that prevents it by the way. There's nothing that prevents it.
Pandora's box is open. It's going to happen to more people more
and more and more now, right? Like nobody understand. Nobody
cares, dude. It's like 50 bucks if you want to do this to somebody.
It's like maybe 500 bucks. Why is nobody talking about how Ethan
Klein by making this a huge high-profile lawsuit is already opening
Pandora's box on this and going to actually over entire communities
of people. The whole political react space going to be [__]
going to be [__] up. Uh people people with money
by the way will be fine as it always is, right? People who can
pay someone to go and like comb through a bot and get them timestamps.
Yeah, they're totally fine. Not going to lie, if I was a streamer,
I don't know if I wouldn't do it. No, you shouldn't do it. You
shouldn't do it cuz you shouldn't create that environment. But
Ethan Ethan's fired the first the first salvo. Okay. The opening
salvo of whatever this this new world is. He's the one who's
done it >> for two months, buddy. Mike calling Ethan Klein
disgusting is just chef's kiss. Uh I would love to. The thing
is that Mike um keeps his VODs
uh
I think you have to be subscribed to watch his VODs. Oh, wait.
No, hang on. Did he change that policy? Is there a time stamp
on one of the streams?
No, you do have to be subscribed. Okay. Yeah. So, he he keeps
that pay. Does when does piece go payw wall the content? Cuz
I feel like the same day you could still watch the VOD. What
is it like two days ago? Says >> alleged Ethan Klein settlement
with Jon further supports everything I've been saying. I'm aware.
>> Do content creators eventually become liable for protecting
their copyright. No, it's not like trade trademarks are different.
You're talking about trademarks, right? That if you don't protect
your trademarks, they go away. That's like what Nintendo does
with Mario and Pokemon and all these other things. You're talking
about trademarks. I think that's different. You do have to protect
trademarks or they can go by the that there's other litigation
ongoing that this case was never about protecting the React community
from a potential lawsuit from Disney or Sony. Ethan's words,
not mine. Nor was it about helping enforce a standard on the
React community, Ethan's central framing, not mine. This case
was never going to establish a precedent legal or cultural on
the React community other than what is already wellknown in American
life. Those with resources are able to vindicate their property
rights using the courts. And there's nothing inherently wrong
with someone protecting their IP, especially not in a strong
case, which I've always maintained this was. But I take issue
with has been specifically focused on the pretense that the lawsuit
is about something greater than that than protecting property
and punishing and humiliating the defendants for their transgressions
perceived or real against Ethan. In his video, Ethan constructs
a fake narrative about protecting the React community, presumably
because one, he's aware that true happy litigation bros are not
usually wellreceived on YouTube, especially when it's the big
guy going after the little guy, and two, Ethan didn't like to
give the answer, quote, "Because I don't like them." End quote.
To the question of why them and not others. So, we have to go
through this absurd song and dance about stated intentional siphoning
and malice and pretend uh that was what was going on. I personally
think it's both.
I personally think it's both. Like, I think Ethan was looking
for a way to hit back against uh some some of the people that
participated in a what I believe to be a particularly cruel internet
pylon, that was just insane. But I also think the fact that they
were so openly malicious, the creators that he sued, that the
fact that they were so openly like brazenly malicious. >> What
does that pylon have to do with copyright again? I forget where
what which pillar of fair use is that Hutch I >> Um did
bring up like genuine um anger about siphoning someone's like
like I think I think
>> yes dumb devil this is true. I'm telling you that what
what happens is
that's how copyright works and the idea is normally it's damages
plus whatever lawyer's fees are if you've infringed on somebody's
copyright, right? But when you re when you register something
with the Library of Congress through the exact method that's
been done with the content nuke, you gain statutory damages.
This is what music companies have done to sue like tornters out
of existence. Okay?
This is like way different. This is a totally different animal,
right? I would have no problem with people if you want to sue
for actual damages, go for it. Yeah, let's go. Do it. Sue for
actual damages right off the bat. I don't care. Right? Don't
use the DMCA system. Sue for actual damages. But when you're
a streamer
and you're suing other people who do like roughly similar things
to you, you're trying to like set the bar so so high versus what
it currently is. And then a ton of people online defend you and
say, "No, you're not trying to set the bar that high that the
bar is like way lower and most people go above it." But they're
just lying. You're just being gaslit into accepting that this
lawsuit's okay. It's not okay. The lawsuit against Adam's totally
okay is completely stupid. >> I I assume uh Ethan was genu.
So, while you can sue anybody at any time for any reason and
that's fine, suing them because you don't like them, picking
them for totally malicious reasons and then lying to people about
it is goofy. And then when you extract your concessions, you
actually extract concess extract concessions primarily about
dramas that you're actually concerned about.
And your job is to pretend that you go out here and you give
your opinion and you're you're putting your opinion out there
and you'll argue with anybody. That's what Ethan's trying to
do.
But he's actually just a crybully who's going to sue people who
criticize him too hard >> that they that they were so malicious
about it. But I think it's both. I think but but I think kind
of he minimizes like this part right here when he says Ethan
didn't like to give the answer quote because I didn't like because
I don't like them. So the question of why them and not others.
It goes beyond Ethan not liking them. Like I feel like this is
very this like rarely minimizes
the impact that was made by those creators like doing the pylon
stuff that lasted for months.
not taking any like
>> like uh is this do we understand that like oh this has
just opened a whole can of worms I can't I can't even start like
it it's actually so blackpilling dude anybody can do this now
and people will do this people will absolutely do this they'll
totally people over right you just make any piece of content
you put it on YouTube you register it with the Library of Congress
you just wait for somebody you don't like to react to it like
all of the richest people with the most resources who can register
all of their content in this way are just totally totally like
criticizing them is dicey as [__] now, right? It
gives you like a pretense for suing people and even in even in
dicey situations, it gives you a pretense for suing them and
you know that even if you didn't damage the person, there's statutory
damages at play. So if you're found guilty, if you if they do
find you liable, sorry, you're [__]
There's going to be so many settlements this could be used to
compel speech constantly.
It's why it never should have been supported in the very first
place. Everybody should have stood on business, stood hand in
hand against these latigious people going after I m maybe you
could argue Casey Tron should have
Okay, cuz it was very egregious copyright infringement. But the
denim thing, man, this everybody needs to stand on this and say
it's wrong. >> Steps to moderate their communities to prevent
the kind of harassment that was going on at the time. That goes
so well beyond Ethan didn't like denims.
This Dane Hutch also remember he won a suit like this from the
opposite side in 2017 that rendered a very broad judgment about
React's content. The filings make multiple mentions of trying
to create precedent to distinguish between lazy and high effort
reactions. My head cannon is that he's trying to fix the prior
ruling with this. I don't know much about the or anything really
about the original case.
Um Keith goes on to say just for calling that out the response
was insane delusion and deflections disappointing because this
is unlike the stand that Ethan took when he was sued by bold
guy a case which was well worth defending and did produce good
precedent in SDNY. See, now you guys tell me. I don't know. I
don't know anything about that original lawsuit. But I have to
assume that the the the factor of maliciousness or malice rather
was not present in that like was Ethan telling his audience,
"Hey, watch this content here so you don't need to watch it there."
>> No, that's not a part of the law. >> Um cuz that's
kind of the big thing
>> No, it's not. No, it's not. No, it's not. No, it's not.
No, it's not. No, it's not. No, it's not. No, it's not. No, it's
not. Um, it's not about React content. It's about intent to siphon.
And for those of you who question whether the intentional siphoning
rut
pre- rapes himself so consistently it's actually funny. Dude,
there's no way he just said that. It's about intent to to pre
its intent to siphon. Oh, wait. Here's a clip of Ethan saying
that XQC siphoning views with the exact thing he did with the
content nuke. Oh, Hutch is >> distinguishes XQC and others.
Look at what said about XQC's conduct before. He called it intentional
siphoning too. It doesn't distinguish anything. We all know the
real reasoning. The real reason. Stop coping. >> The same.
Why is it you you think it's crazy, dude? The fact that you're
using the same title and the same thumbnail is so parasitic.
It's so shady. You You are only doing that to siphon off views
and confuse people. There's no other reason for that. Why would
you use the same exact title and the same exact thumbnail? Explain
that to me. >> So, are you more excited about the title
or the kind of video itself? >> Well, it's the intention,
dude. It's all It's all together. You're you're intentionally
confusing people to click your videos. Why is it you >> doesn't
it isn't it very plausible like very plausible that the reason
why he didn't target XQC and Azimold Hassan and other really
big creators who watched it or I guess Hassan didn't watch it
until after their
He's literally going to say, "Isn't it possible? Isn't it possible
that Ethan really thinks getting punched in the face is worse
than somebody saying they're going to punch him in the face?"
Like, leave alone whether they punch him in the face. Isn't it
so much worse to actually say you're going to punch Ethan in
the face? Like, that's like anti-semitic. He's And anti-semitism,
as we all know, is the biggest crime
>> or after, I don't remember.
Um, but XQC didn't didn't I mean like maybe the assumption was
that he would have a much harder time in a court case against
XQC because XQC did not tell his audience, "Hey, you care so
you don't give Ethan a view." That seems totally plausible, right?
Um, these those people didn't explicitly show their mouths. Like
what I'm saying is this clip I don't think necessarily contradicts
Ethan's decision to target the specific creators that he did
with litigation because there is a massive distinction like it
is totally plausible that Ethan felt like that would be a much
more difficult case to to win without that element of exp.
So now here's how this is going to go. Pisco is going to go,
"Oh, do you think intent matters? Let's talk about it." And Hutch
is going to go, "No, I don't really care that much, actually.
No, I don't really want to do that, actually." I hope I hope
Hutch or I hope Pisco sees this clip where Hutch says, "Well,
I think it's m this malice thing is a big deal, right?" It's
not. Pisco just argued it wasn't, right? >> Bliss malice,
right? >> Oh my goodness. >> XQC also has a thousand
times the pockets. He could prolong the case indefinitely. I
mean, that's the other thing, too, right? No, >> XQC is
not as vulnerable to being totally legally
with. Okay. So, why would he do that? He can't He can't get XQC
to dance around and call himself a piggy. Why would he sue him?
He could get Caseyron to dance around and and say she's a piggy.
Why would she? Of course, he's going to sue Caseyron and not
XQC.
We keep telling Pisco that, but he hand waves it away because
he wants to be contrarian against Eden FOR SOME REASON. >> OH
MY GOD. Like in the replies, I think.
>> gotta be careful on Twitter, man. you never know when
you click on something if it's like going to show up or whatever.
Um, but I think in the in the replies Pisco said something like
he he was not like really aware of the lore. He didn't really
understand Ethan's like beef with these creators that predated
the content nuke. And it's kind of like, you know, I feel like
maybe, you know, it might be a good idea to take some time to
look into that to understand like where the animosity comes from
and
the uh like the backstory to all this stuff. have a statement.
But for the >> I love that Hutch is like, "Listen, Peace
Go, if he understood the context of the history of the harassment
that Ethan is under, he would understand why this copyright claim
is valid." And and then Hutch would when he gets asked about
the the Matt Hos lawsuit, Hutch goes, "Oh, I don't know anything
about that lawsuit. I don't know about copyright law, but I think
Pisco would better understand this copyright case if he looked
into the history of how Ethan's been harassed." Like skulls,
like swords, like CPS. Okay, that would actually give him a way
better preced way better understanding of how this is going.
No, I think Pisco is going to stick with the law, Hutch. I think
he's he'd much rather stick with the law. The law probably gives
him a better indication of how this legal case will go. I'm just,
you know, it's a hypothesis, but I think it's valid. I think
it's valid,
dude. Uh
I don't think Hutch saw Pisco is gunning for anyone questioning
him. Oh, this is the Dan tweet. Hold on. Seen a clip of Dan Kan's
stream where he calls my take on Ethan lawsuit stupid and says
that I'm stupid. Once again offering for maybe the 10th time
to talk to Dan regarding this. His continuing refusal to engage
speaks
That's there once you stop engaging once you stop like talking
to people you sort of like it's one of those things you know
how Jordan Peterson used to say if you put conel compelled speech
in the law it will become prevalent in all parts of the law like
that compulsion will become prevalent. That's what it is when
you like stop talking to people. When you have like something
you don't want brought up, so you stop talking to people. It
sort of spiders out into everything. You can't talk to like anyone
ever. So these people all have things that they don't want brought
up. And so they can't go talk to people anymore. It just doesn't
work, right? They'll only talk to people who they can control
the conversation with. So no, nobody thinks they can control
Pisco in a conversation, so they're not going to talk to him
ever.
Very interesting.
Very very neat. Is that Moot? Yeah, there's a podcast. They do
anything else with Mr. Mutin and Dan. Now, crazy stuff. Crazy
stuff.
Where are we on this? This guy. This guy. I think, bro, we need
to [laughter] Can we I'm just saying probably if you had like
roughly this time stamp for Hutch's stream. You could probably
go clip this and then Pisco on Twitter and say Hutch is saying
that intent matter. Oh, wait. Not this one, though. This one?
No, not this one.
Where is he watching the Pisco thing? I just had it. What? This
is him talking about Oh. Oh, this one. Yeah, it is this one.
You go back from this one a little bit. You could you could clip
that and you could totally kosho
Pisco
questioning the the malicious intent thing over and over again.
Okay, I'm sure I'm sure Pisco would want to talk about it for
sure. >> Audience and Pedo's fans, the people misogyny,
they just care that she's saying this stuff damned. >> Ethan
really does remind me of Alex Jones now. a piece of [__]
human who does nothing but cause harm to the world but will fundamentally
never feel actual consequences for the damages that he causes
people.
>> Wrong.
Wrong. You're wrong.
You're >> Holy [__] dude. That's just cuz we're
not there yet. You're only seeing this today, not the full trajectory.
This is insane, dude. I love this. I love this so much. This
is so fun, dude. I'm having so much fun tonight. Disco already
said he might bring it up and live and learn. Let's go.
>> They are so >> It's extremely revealing they need
putting in that part about Asmin Gold. This whole thing has been
fan service for the incel that attacked her incessantly. A B
and Lena using their fundraiser as a cud. >> Thank you
for the [__] disgusting.
>> Is this like a video game thing in the background? What
is this? Much of that money was donated by the same people.
don't care anymore. Oh my god, they we're out. We're out. We're
out.
Okay, hold on. We need to find
What are we finding?
Oh, somebody gave me a time stamp for quick uncip. What?
What? What? What? Hold on. What is this?
>> Shannon Sharp on how slurs are not openly used in movies
and music like black slurs. If you peel back the layers, they
own everything. Oh, dude. Black people.
[laughter] Dude.